Okay. Poor people on Twitter. I made them
wait for like five minutes with a lie.
I said we were ready to go, but it really,
I was being optimistic. Brian Catlin,
I understand that you understand,
do you understand the pressure that
we're under this episode sponsored by
Squarespace. Squarespace is a website
that allows you to build your own, uh,
personal or business
website yourself easily. Um,
they have over 20 bad ass designs.
You can get a Giddy at 24,
seven support from super fast email
support that there like there if you,
you can't figure it out how to do it,
but it's really easy to do.
You're going to get it. I can get
it. Brian's done a million of them.
They have it set up so it looks
great on Ipad, android, iPhone,
everything.
I'm not even a tech guy and I use it.
It works because they sponsored my, yeah,
it's so, it's so easy to use. It's, it's,
it's like one of the coolest websites
ever as far as like a functional websites
for creating websites,
including um,
putting together a store and you can
put together an online store and like 10
clicks. It's, it's, it's stupid
easy. I don't know if it's 10 clicks,
don't hold me to that, but
you could figure it out. I'm
using it to set up my, or
they're so confident about it that they
let you try it before you even buy it.
So he can try their,
their website creating process and you
don't even have to enter a credit card.
And then if you decide to use it, you
say, you know what I'm going to use?
This is going to be my website now.
Then you enter in your credit card,
you use the code Joe and the number eight
for the month of August and you'll get
a 10% is it September yet?
Shit, it is September.
It did become some stuff
like God, September 1st you
guys mess around day, dude,
it's September 2nd.
That's the second day to day,
but it's Labor Day so you
don't have to do shit. Yay.
That's you sound like an
awesome dude to run a house too.
Anyway. Uh, let's just go
with Joe nine then. Fuck it.
But either one of them work Joey or Joe
Nine. Either one will get you 10% off.
I think it's just for
their sake monitoring.
When you decided when my commercial
sucked at a certain point. Dot.
If two people that have to be like,
you know, you know he sent it in it in.
I know he has. I know he really
doesn't give a fuck about Squarespace.
He said it too many times.
It can't mean anything anymore.
But one of the things we try to do on
the shows, anything that we advertise,
we try to make sure it's legit.
Squarespace.
Squarespace seems very legit as far as
the responses we've gotten from people
that have tried it,
it's been overwhelmingly
positive. So I'm willing to,
I'm willing to back it.
I think it's a good product and it looked
pretty bad ass and Brian County uses
it as I do and Brian red bands made
like a hundred websites with it. Okay.
And we're also brought to you.
You is that still up?
Squirt Burt still up fears legs.
It's still up.
I'll get off and there's legs.
They sell anything at arch feels legs.
He should just be plastic.
Homer Simpson miles. That's it.
Deep inside joke.
We're also brought to
you by legal zoom. Legal Zoom is a website
that allows you to create your own, uh,
I shouldn't say create your own legal
documents, but fill out legal documents.
Things like an LLC you can do for $99.
That's what it starts at.
You can incorporate or form an LLC without
going to a lawyer and paying a lot of
money. He could do it naked. That's
what I've been trying to promote.
People masturbating while
using legal zoom. I mean,
I really want you to proofread, so go over
your stuff. Make sure he got it right,
but as you can,
if I could prove that more people use
legal zoom from my website because of them
being naked, take pictures. It's the
government's looking at you, man.
They're looking at you right to
that camera. That's what I hear.
That little camera right there. And I
was everywhere. I just turn them on.
I had a porn lawyer, this guy had
on my podcast say that, uh, he,
he wouldn't do any of those chat rooms
or anything because those cameras are
working at somebodies recording.
I'm sure at this point the, the,
the ship has sailed. Yeah. It's ship
has sailed. You know, if you're,
if you're beaten off, someone's got
a video of it, there's no doubt.
So, um, that's all going to come out in
the wash. But the reality is if you, um,
if you want to save money and get
some shit done, like writing a will,
it's very easy to do.
Legal Zoom can also connect you with
an independent attorney if you panic.
Like if you get in the middle of that
Shit and you're filling out forms or like
I'm going to go to jail,
he may have be me too. Um,
um, yeah. It's funny how we have blind
spots to that stuff. Big Law, legal stuff,
financial stuff. Why we have massive
add my friend, massive add can't.
There's certain things you can talk
about me and just start talking about
options and swaps.
I'm like Greek.
It sounds like great walking away
from you right now. I taught the crazy
swaps like wife swaps.
Wild that that too,
but that makes me panic and dude willing
to swap wives. You don't want that one.
I know what I'm saying.
He's given us taller.
Do you think that like
when you get older though,
that's actually just something you do?
Sure.
Like when you were like 60 70 like you
just start swapping wives when we've
discussed this before. When you're 60 or
70 go walk down the beach, go fishing.
Your time is over. Nobody wants to
fuck you. Even if they do, fuck you.
It's going to be a disaster.
You know they're going to look at
you while you're fucking them and go.
All marks the hardest I've ever
laughed and my life was watching.
You do stand up on what it's like for
those girls to have sex with with you.
Half of it was like they're lucky.
They're lucky, lucky, lucky.
Please don't paraphrase.
It says zero to do with legal.
zoom.com has a great fit. Have you done
that recently? No, I can't do it anymore.
It's over. I don't feel that way anymore.
Anyway. Legal Zoom is not a law form.
They provide self help service
at your specific discretion.
What direction? You said La Forum
Forum Forum. It's not a forum.
It's a forum or a form or a a
legal zoom is not a law firm.
It's a weird word from it means so many
different things like a group of people
and like a nice ass.
Why?
It's also not something you could really
describe what man as as a straight man
you can't be like,
you know it's from from guy.
What's kind of bond a
things like a firm look,
you know a guy can give you a firm look.
Yeah,
firm handshake do with touching. So
that's the thing. Like he can't be like,
he's very firm. Right? But isn't it
weird? We also use law firm for that.
It's we're, we're like, why did we run out
of fucking words for Shit? I don't know.
He say he's from on the
price is very flat price.
Why English is like one of the most
difficult languages to learn actually.
Apparently it is.
Yeah.
That's what keeps us stupid
and preoccupied trying to
figure out our language.
Anyway, go to legal zoom.com use a
codeword Rogan. Save yourself some money.
It's a an excellent service. I highly
recommend it. There's a lot of shit.
Uncle creepy is going to try to do his,
it's Ian Mccall.
UFC fighters going to try and do is
divorce through illegal zoom. Really?
I hope he's getting a sponsor for that.
They don't see,
it's not a law firm though,
so I don't know.
I mean they could probably
like give it to them for free.
I think that's the issue is like
they can't do it for him. Yeah. Yeah.
He's going to have to do himself. Not
me. I came gave away your whole house.
I marked 100% not 50% yeah, dude,
it's legal and some of the,
I've,
I've read some legal things before
and it's like, oh no wonder why.
There's debates on
interpretations of some things.
The other thing that I think about is
like if you ever sign a tax return or you
buy a house or something or, or a car.
I just signed, I'm not reading anything.
I'm literally like, what? Okay, sign here.
Just sign this release. I know. Yeah,
it's sweet. It's sweet. It says
you're a sweetie or sweets.
Who would be nice to each
other anyway, legal, zoom.com
code name, Rogan. God. Tim,
he's a taking a lot longer
than I wanted them to.
I was trying to get through a quick
today, a g, g plus Mu. Anyway,
this episode is also brought to
by a on it.com o. N. N. I. T.
We have the newest kettle bells in
and our primal kettle bell series.
It's a rang a Tang.
It's a 1.5 pooed Aubrey promises.
We're going to put the weights. Any
stupid things? Yeah. What is it? Food?
Is it a [inaudible]?
So rush should method of a measurement
and old school method like stone for,
you know, for English. English stone
is, what is it? 13 pounds, 14 pounds.
Pooed I think one Puente is 35 pounds.
So two pood is 70.
And what would that make? One and a half
pooed it's 54. Is that what it is? Yeah,
but that's not an orangutan.
That's a chimp and I, and
I'm on a mountain gorilla.
No, no. There's a chimp,
a mountain gorilla,
an orangutan [inaudible]
tanks in the middle. That's,
that's just simply incorrect.
Just a wide face champion.
No, it's, if you had, if it
had color to it, it would
look like, so I'm going to say
they're all evenly balanced.
This is one of the most important
things about when decided to create
these things. The guy who
did them, I mean, I kind of
need to find out who it is,
who the actual artist is and credit
him because he's fucking amazing. Um,
I'm going to text RB
while the show's going.
Those are almost things you could have
like, you know, greeting your guests,
you know, on either side of
the door. Yeah. Yeah. Their
artwork, door weights there,
or artwork as much as they are.
That's why I wanted,
if I had to rob a house when I
saw those on the front porch,
I might choose another house
having a pit bull.
Maybe it's insecurity thing.
I can't just work out with weights.
I have to work out with weights that look
like gorillas. I want to scare bitch.
We sell uh,
all kinds of different shit.
I'm trying to write to a all
brewed right now. Who's the artist,
Bro?
Right now people are listening.
Go edit the shit out, bitch. Sorry,
I should have edited that out.
But uh, I had a text and a,
I'm not that good at texting.
I'm not that good at texting. I'm,
I'm a little annoyed and big, thick,
blonde thumbs. That's also a little
annoyed that after all these years, um,
my phone is trying to pretend
that I didn't say fucking yeah,
I know and I have to go back. I didn't
say duck going, you fucking change.
I wrote Af, you know, I wrote
out. Right. Why did they do that?
Because more people would,
we,
it can't assume that you're going to make
a swear because then what if it makes
that assumption and it makes a swear when
you meant to write, ducking, playing,
like you know, you were ducking, you
got fucking between dock. Whoa. Yeah.
It has to go with doc. Yeah.
That's a big difference.
Like you were ducking or you were
fucking like, did you see me? Why not?
One, you don't give a fuck face other you
get divorced or yeah. Or people panic.
Like was high.
She's a fuck.
Yeah. Anyway. Um, battle
ropes, kettlebells,
medicine balls,
all kinds of different shit.
That's all designed for
total human optimization.
That's the idea behind a lifting weights
with a w or things that would give you
functional strength.
It's very difficult stuff.
So I always recommend people start
out light and get some instruction.
If you can go to a professional
trainer or someone who's RKC certified,
preferably someone who really knows how
to do kettlebells and spend whenever
they charged, you know, like whatever
a session is and just like videotape.
It is plenty of videos out there
that are really good as well.
We sell a couple of them
on on it. Uh, the um,
Keith Weber videos are excellent
extreme kettlebell cardio DVDs.
Just absolutely fantastic stuff.
And um,
but I think it's really important if
you've never lifted any weights before to
have someone show you how to do
it correctly, start out light,
use good form and will, you'll get
real benefits for a health and fitness.
It's a,
it's great for functional strength.
Even if you're just talking
about like things around
plus it makes you look sexy as fuck. Can
I? Oh, thank you. [inaudible] for days.
I call him Joe shoulders
for days, Rogan. Um,
we also sell a bunch of different
vitamins and supplements.
Use a codename Rogan and you'll save
10% off any and all supplements.
I just did that.
I just changed that.
Pooed and the whole time
you were saying that,
I said that's how we need to fix
that. Easy. He probably hasn't,
you need to get website authors.
Can I take those kettle bells with me
when I'm in Raleigh, North Carolina.
Did there you son of a bear.
Good Nights.
Hi Charlie Goodnight's old school
comedy club right there. I'm excited.
That place has been around
for a long time. I loved that
place. The green room is,
you're in the way of all the waitresses.
No Green Room.
Like when you try to,
you have to like stand in this like little
box area that's near the waitresses.
So he's like, oh, excuse me,
sorry. And they're all like,
we need 706 we need five over here.
Great Place.
Old School place tempered 12th,
13th 14th. Yeah. I love doc joint.
That's like a real one
of the last old school,
real comedy clubs in this country. I,
every time I could do it a club like that.
And I see they have an old school
club in Atlanta. There's another one,
xannies and Nash. There's another place
called [inaudible] in Santa San Jose.
I can't remember the name of it.
Um, ah, I wish I could remember it,
but it's the same thing.
Tiny place and all school.
I mean the woodcreeks. Yeah,
just, yeah, this, that's just
like Charlie goodnight's.
That's a great, great like
institution of a club. You know,
you're a skeptic.
I wonder if you took a,
the wood from an old comedy clubs had
been laughed. There was just, it did the,
absorbed all the waves of
laughter through the years.
What that would be different than say
the woods asked us actual on the actual
pod, Cuban music, which just get
to start. I should already start.
Let's go teaser question,
teaser question.
I dragged everything from on and on.
Experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Hello. My friends were talking
to, um, the Great Brian Cowen,
who'll be a Charlie goodnight's
this weekend in North Carolina.
If you're listening to this live
or within the next couple of days.
And then we're also talking to the
Midwest. Midwest is a guy who, uh,
came onto my podcast or on my
television show rather than the Scifi,
uh, Joe Rogan questions, everything
where we, uh, wanted to discuss a,
a bunch of issues.
And then I found out that he has a website
that is devoted entirely to debunking
things.
I had known about your website before.
Contrail science as it contrasts
science.org or.com.com.
I read that. Write this down. Contrail
contrail science and it's very, uh,
it's very detailed and very easy.
The way it explains what
certain are misconstruing
for being poisonous spray that's coming
out of planes and what's actually an
effect of jet airplanes flying
through clouds and that explanation.
I remember reading that going,
oh, that totally makes sense.
Like I get it.
They're seeing it come out of the plane
and they think that this has never
happened before or that this is a, this
is a new thing. This is geoengineering.
They're spraying over ahead.
They're not telling us about it.
And the [inaudible] want to think that
it's a geoengineering that's like the big
one,
that they're geoengineering.
That's the main explanation that people
and what's geoengineering,
here's what's fucked,
what's fucked as they are, try
to cool the planet. I mean,
it's not that they're doing it on purpose,
but we are doing it by flying
and making those clouds.
It is geoengineering eyes.
And one of the things that I really
enjoy about what you're doing is that you
have a very specific sort of mandate and
the idea is to expose these silly ideas
so that you can concentrate on real ones.
You know?
And when you were talking
about chem trails,
one of the things that really struck
me was that was that how much time and
effort is spent on things that can be
debunked and how they really just distract
from things like the NSA tapping into
all your emails and being able to monitor
anyone's phone if those
are like real issues.
Yeah. Like, and the people who are
into chem trails and things like that,
a lot of them are very
energetic people who yes,
they spend a lot of time doing this stuff
and they could be spending that time
on a,
on real issues.
Yeah.
And it's not that this is the big one,
it's not that no one has ever
experimented on the public before.
The fucking for sure they have.
We know about the Tuskegee experiment,
we know that they,
they sprayed that shit out of the
top of buildings in Saint Louis.
We know that they've experimented
with things that probably weren't the
healthiest for the population.
But when you start calling
everything you see in the clouds,
a conspiracy and everything,
you see when a jet engine passes through
it without like really looking into the
possible details of it like that, it gets,
it gets to be almost like a religion.
It is.
Yeah. It is. Yeah. I think that that's,
you know, people, they have that same,
that faith basically, that, uh,
you know what they believe is correct and
they didn't actually need the evidence
to back that up. So if you're asked
them, you know, where's the evidence?
They say it's obvious, and they just
say, look up at the sky. Uh, they, they,
you know, it's like people who
have religious experiences, they,
they pray to God and God tells
them that they are right. Uh,
people in the chem trail community,
a lot of people in the country
and community have this, this,
this religious sense of
being very, um, very, um,
sure about their ideas.
And they have basically gone
beyond evidence. Now the,
in the post evidence stage, a lot of
them about how, you know, the, the,
the time for proving chem trails
he's passed because, you know, we,
we know it's happening,
it's obvious.
So it's very difficult to
deal with those people to,
to talk to them because they don't
want to listen to the evidence that are
moving onto the next day.
Aren't you describing a fanatic
in a sense? I mean, well,
they are fanatical in their belief,
but the idea that there's no,
I can no longer be challenged. The, the,
the debate has been settled and now it's
just a question of whether you, you,
you are a convert or you are an enemy.
I mean, that's kind of the idea.
Yeah.
So for those type of people,
I tried to frame the discussion
a bit differently. Uh,
you need to ask them like what would be
the next stage and you're not going to
start shooting down planes or even
though some people do actually to to just
talk about shooting downplay.
And so I've got a whole long thread
on the forum of people who, you know,
say things like,
let's shoot him down.
There's people who actually do go out
with laser pointers and point them at the
planes that are chem trails.
Here's my problem with it all and this
is what really freaked me out. What,
where is,
where's their tipping point?
Like how far do you look into it before
you willing to resort to violence?
Like how much evidence are they
getting that that's what's happening?
There's a weird disconnect going on
here because if you were looking at the
whole thing and if you looked at the
explanations and you looked at the
explanations where they're clearly
stating in mainstream news that there's,
there's artificial clouds
that are created by jets.
It's a part of the 2002
article on cnn.com.
And it's about after nine 11,
they measured the skies and they found
that the artificial clouds that are
created by jets flying around all the
time that they actually were cooling the
planet, the planet got hotter like
a measurably hotter without that
during the day. It actually, uh,
well it, it's when that happened,
it to warmed up during the day and
killed down during the night. Uh, the,
the jets don't actually really do one
thing very much. They do in the day they,
uh, the, the controls or block the sun
and at night they block the heat leaving,
right?
So the net result is a very slight
warming because there's more of an effect
from the trapping of the thing at night.
So during the nine 11 shutdown, uh,
what was seen was there was, uh, an
increase in the range of temperatures.
So my, my point was that it is still
is a fascinating point of discussion.
Even if it's not chemicals
being sprayed from the sky,
even if it is this, not, excuse me,
even if it is not this
nefarious government scheme
to control the weather. Yeah,
it is still fascinating and because we're,
we're having an effect on the
environment by, by flying around period.
So in a sense the,
the idea behind chem trails like the
chem trail theorists and conspiracists,
the, what they're doing
is you're, you're, you're,
you have a real problem and you're
focusing on a fake ineffective problem and
the fake ineffective problem being
that they're spraying as to poison us,
they're causing more Johns
what an incredibly ineffective
program that would be.
Do you know how much money
the government is spending?
How would you even organize that in the
government as if you could keep that a
secret as if the US government could
keep something like that secret anyway.
I mean just stop and think about how
crazy it is that you would think that
something which does such a shit
job is still going on as a program.
We're pretty goddamn healthy.
People are living longer than ever.
The cure cancers that used to
kill you just a few years ago.
It's like if you're taking care of
your body and you're eating healthy,
if you can afford to do that,
you can live pretty good right now.
Yeah, and that's one of the things
like with fluoride in the water,
people say Florida is
it's poisoning people,
but you know the water's being fluoridated
for for decades and there really
hasn't been any, any noticeable
differences in health of people.
That is Laurie and fluoride,
but there also hasn't been any evidence
to indicate that fluoride is good for,
for dental hygiene or anything.
It's a bit of a gps thing to like it
should be poured into the water period.
Right? If it's not aiding in, in
taking away anything dangerous
science. The fact that Florida
actually does retard tooth decay,
but I do not know if that's true
because the reason I say that is because
they've done a lot of comparisons
between, the reason, first of all,
I think it was even
discovered was wasn't it?
There was a couple of towns in Colorado
where kids were just not getting
cavities. Well, what was going on?
They found that there were
a natural fluoride deposits
in there in the water and
it may have been, I think it
was Colorado. And then, uh,
then they started doing
things and scientist said yes.
In fact a fluoride ref makes it more
and more unlikely that you'll get tooth
decay and then they compared fluoride
this country with the countries overseas
that did not far dies. They're fluff
fluorinate or whatever the word is there,
their water. And there was
a market difference in, in
it is the science is real, that it
does actually prevents it. But it's,
it's kind of a more of a
broader demographic thing.
Like for the total population, does it
actually have a, a worthwhile effect?
Cause most people brush
their teeth nowadays with
fluoride toothpaste. Yeah. Uh,
and back in the olden days,
that wasn't a common thing,
especially with poor people.
And so the floor reduction programs,
but kind of aims more
at the poor people who,
who had poor dental hygiene and you know,
the middle classes and upper middle class,
it's people who had money and taught the
kids how to brush their teeth properly.
They didn't really benefit
from fluoridation at all.
And nowadays it's a lot more common
for people to be brushing their teeth.
So there's even less of a reason to do it.
But there still is the,
there's still a segments of the
population who don't have very good dental
hygiene who probably would benefit
from fluoridation, but you know,
it's like math.
And
so is it a necessary component for,
for dental hygiene or is it just that
hygiene is a necessary component.
And then if you were having a
person who's doing it today,
over the last x amount of years,
toothpaste has been fluoridated.
What s what sample study do you have
of people that are not using fluoride?
Uh, you know, as forward
it to the Amish, the Amish.
I may maybe like,
I'm, I have that Tom's of Maine,
I've had that stuff before.
It doesn't have Florida and it's pretty
good toothpaste, just because it kind of,
it kind of weirds me out that fluoride
is dangerous. I mean, you can't,
you can't have it enlarged psalms.
And obviously you could say that about
salt or a lot of other things as well.
But Florida doesn't seem to be like a
natural thing that we should consume.
I mean, is, is there, it
is a natural occurring, uh,
can be in the water.
All water,
like a natural spring water. It's
a mineral, isn't it? Or is it a,
yeah, something like that. So it comes
from that. If you die from fluoride,
you're pretty big pussy
though. What was the, uh,
the knock, the conspiracy theorists?
Maybe you can help us on this.
The conspiracy theory about it was a, that
it was created by the Nazis that they,
uh, it was a part of the
mind control effort to keep
people stupid. They, Florida,
Florida, the water, I mean,
the Internet was vetted on,
I have a lot of those people were
probably at apple were and et cetera.
We're doing, we're drinking
far. I like, I can't hear you.
Gotta you gotta look at the, yeah.
What's happened? How's it worked out?
People stupid it nowadays you might. Yeah.
A lot of people ask you to be noticed,
but yeah, Iq is and how
stupid. That's a terrible
thing.
I was thinking,
we don't realize how stupid people are
until you're running the stupid people,
because if you're a smart person,
he traveled in smart circles,
you can get really delusional if you live
in a nice town where people have their
shit together and you're,
you know, interacting with
pretty intelligent people.
You could forget that. Essentially this
parts of the world, parts of our country,
even that looked like an episode of
the walking dead. Yeah. You know,
and that's it.
I didn't even think of it as stupid
when I travel as much as you know,
we both travel a lot. I actually am
always amazed at how apathetic people are,
just how they just are not interested
in anything that they can't eat or touch
or feel. There's no, there's no,
it doesn't always seem to be a lot
of imagination out there. Yeah.
There's a weirdness to this world that
we're living in right now where people
are looking to be distracted
more so than ever.
Partly partly because you can
distract yourself very effective. Yep,
that's true too.
But there's not that much of a push to
get the fuck away from it. You know?
I think that like,
it sounds crazy,
but I think that like if there's not some
sort of a push to get away from stupid
silly thinking,
it's really difficult to find
the motivation to take a,
I think human beings have always
done that when they had to write.
Think about how many inventions came out
of war out of the necessity of trying
to beat the other side. So you're not
specking said Dortch, et cetera. I mean,
a lot of, a lot of invent,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
but a lot of technological advances were
a direct result of having to come up
with a solution to a problem or you know,
a very immediate problem in
the space program as well.
Basically came out of the Cold War.
It was this because we had this big
enemies that we had to fight. Two,
you can pull this resources
into, you know, going to the
moon and stuff like that,
which was completely unnecessary
thing. Um, but you know,
guests conflict is a big driving
force. Safety, safety and pleasure.
This is an interesting cavity.
Rates
declined in several cities that stopped
war. I'd flow water fluoridation,
new studies report contradicting
American dental association predictions
according to the fluoride action network,
by the way, who the who are the floor,
that's where the speed,
you're dedicating all your time to flora
obscure jobs as if this is a few fairly
serious people who don't
like the fluoridation thing.
Like actual scientists.
Yeah. Oh yes. That's the case behind
it. It's not this totally French thing,
but it becomes fringe when you get
into things like know the government is
adding it secretly.
So to brainwash people.
Or the other one that I've heard is that
the government added it because there
was some sort of a deal that they had
made with the producers of fluoride.
He's like less than say you're going
to dump this and I want to hear,
you're gonna pay us every year.
So you got to kick back,
you're going to kick back. Your kids are
going to kick back. But it's ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous theory.
But it sounds like got something
the government would do.
We're trying to get rid of toxic waste
and the only thing that could think of to
do was to put it in the water supply.
Yeah. I mean, who gets rid of toxic waste?
But I didn't get to the water supply.
I think the company that makes toxic
wigs are in league with Satan. And uh,
so as the government that
allow this to happen,
they don't care that they're washing
their own bodies with this water and all
the elites, if they're spring water
shipped in from the center of the earth,
comes sterilized by the lava.
It's super delicious.
And once you vote Republican for 10
years in a row, they come to your house.
We'll give you the good water.
Got to Switzerland and they have
their blood to look clean. Yes.
She got to go to Switzerland machines.
We'll see.
Do they do do some interesting
procedures overseas?
Do you know anything about
like those blood splinting,
spinning procedures are doing [inaudible]?
Isn't that platelet rich sort of
like that, but I guess it's not,
it's there's something more to it.
It's just not just platelet rich plasma
treatment, but there's added elements.
I have no idea.
I don't understand it,
but all these athletes are having these
incredible results going over there.
Like Dana White, he cured his maneuvers
disease with one shot. He's really, yeah,
apparently a lot of diseases are based
on inflammation and what this stuff
essentially is.
What it creates is this super anti
inflammation agent that's made out of your
own blood and I don't
understand the process at all,
but apparently during the
Bush administration it was
really difficult to do stem
cell research.
Difficult to,
difficult to get funding
for a lot of things.
And if anything that involves stem cells,
even if it's like a tiny
fraction of a bunch of cells,
you know, like a hundred
cells or something like that.
Something so small you'd have to
look at under a microscope to see it.
So because of that,
I think Europe was allowed to experiment
with a lot of like really interesting
different methods for using
stem cells and, and different,
different treatments of using the
stuff that's made out of your own body,
like taking your blood and turning
it into Madison. It's really
kind of crazy.
The idea that inflammation is like the
cause of suddenly there was an article
recently in New York Times about
a guy with a physician who said,
why are we not telling people about
the benefits of low grid aspirin,
81 milligrams or something like that,
which apparently has a very, very,
uh, um, measurable results
in, in stopping things like,
uh, or at least retarding, uh,
things like colon cancer, even, uh,
all kinds of diseases because it,
it brings inflammation down in the body.
And uh, you know, just just look
right at Aspen. Listen Dude,
I'm reading Argo article right now
on wake up world.com, and it says,
prove to anyone that fluoride is bad
for you and dumbing society down.
Hmm.
Did you imagine if we found out that
our leaders were really pouring stuff in
the water to try to make everybody dumb,
but let's say that we're the delusion
of ones and that these folks were all
right and that is the elites.
They are not getting fluoride water and
they're just doing it to dumb people
down. That's the most extreme
of the theories, right? Yeah.
I guess just done at a local level though.
It's not even like a national thing.
The elites get a cut back.
When people use words like
the elite or the government,
the government's always changing and
there's so much infighting in the
government. A lot of times people
try to stab each other in the back.
It'd be hard to kind of get a one small
groups. The shelter, they also, yeah,
they also need funding. I
found the fluoride action
network, by the way, Joe. Nice.
Those guys look really happy.
That's one thing I always say when I
see a gay guys to get the Tilex so it
happened like so happy. They look happy.
They're not conflicted at all. You know,
gay. They don't, they don't have
an issue of you being a woman.
They also get to hang with another dude.
How do you understand so well,
why is this guy in this guy? No,
he's too high. He's too tall. Look,
he's peeing on his jacket off.
He's using his butt cheeks to hold his
balls and bliss. If I had to guess weird,
if I had to go, I say fun. This, this, uh,
and then the second theory is that
there's some sort of a cover up going on
because they sell this, they have a
deal to sell this fluoride to the,
to the water people and the water people
put it in and this is kickback sort of
a deal. I've heard that
theory to, can you read that?
It's such a small amount of money in the
global scheme of things like poisoning
the, until I population just
to make like $1 billion.
Maybe he has one of those giant twisty
mustaches like Tait Fletcher is rocking
these days and he's really
just like a surfer dude.
Todd has the most glorious mustache. The
world has ever known. Fantastic things.
Everybody should have a mustache. Fuck
that guy. Should I love that too. Shit.
Toughest Shit.
Sweet and smart and and and very smart.
But he's a sweetie too. He's a really
nice guy. He's just a sandwich.
Maybe if he had fluoride in his water,
anything a little more calm.
I was going to say drinking too much
fucking spring water. That's what happens.
Peter though.
If you can put salt
Peter on the water and it actually
kills boners prison. Really?
This isn't that what they used to
give priests? There was, I don't know.
They said they gave her and I know they
use it and I, from my own understanding,
I guess I use it in prison.
The priest take that stuff the way,
like when you know a kidnappers trying
to drug a woman and she figures out a way
to put it under a tongue and a movie
and spit the medication away. Defiantly.
Yeah. That's how the priests take that.
Saul, Peter, I saw Peter Tapping. Yeah.
Who the fuck is going to take something
that kills your boners and people would
theoretically, but when push came
to shove, they would go, wait, what?
What does it do? You know, you'd go, yeah,
I don't even want my sexuality anymore.
I'm done. I give up and then, okay,
well we're going to give you a pill that
kills it permanently. Forever. I got it.
I'll get to that pill. And
you go, wait, what happens?
I just sit on the couch all day.
What else is there to do?
My boner is what drives me everywhere.
Um, did you see any of, uh,
the, uh, Joe Rogan questions?
Everything on, um, human
optimization on a transcendence?
No, that's the one I mentioned.
That's literally the best
one in my opinion. My, my,
my favorite one to do because, uh,
it was on a very controversial topic.
The idea of taking a human
mind and breaking it down
to ones and Zeros and then
downloading it into something
that we create. Singularity. Yeah.
Whether it is computer or whether it's
an artificial body that you know has an
artificial brain and like literally
like a bolt to the back of your head and
your,
your Usb to Usb in your brain and all
sudden Brian Callen exists in a super body
because you're running around jumping
over buildings and you're not even made
out of tissue anymore.
You made out of carbon fiber and then
I'll finally have the athleticism.
I think everyone's going to be at some
point in time, but that is the big, uh,
the big theory is how much of this is
science fiction or the big discussion
rather is how much of this is science
fiction because the idea of being able to
add escape, escape your biologic 100%
right? Yeah. And to be able to, to,
to get the mind and somehow know,
transport the consciousness
into something else.
Maybe there's no one has
ever shown. Yeah, we,
no one's ever shown that we can even
isolate where consciousness comes from.
We know that,
you know,
we believe it's created by the
brain because of a bunch of factors.
But the brain could be just like a really
sophisticated instrument for tuning in
the consciousness of your entire body.
Well,
or the way that these
mathematicians are now calling, uh,
the idea that our brain may
very well be a hologram. Uh,
what we see as a mathematical
hologram of some kind.
This guy had on my podcast as an author,
went and talked to all these big time,
uh, mathematicians at MIT because he was
trying to work on this book. And they,
they were like, well, I mean, the latest
theory if you really want to hear it,
is that this is one big
hologram and you're, you were
actually,
there's a another dimension to our
minds that we haven't thought about yet.
I was like, what are you talking about?
What are you even saying? But it was,
you know,
this is all these guys done numbers too.
That's what's really fucked about those
theoretical quantum physicists guys.
They'll show you like in numbers.
Well,
they said that that this
is where they started with,
they said if you were to
take all the space away from
what's what you're made of,
say you're made of atoms and
it's mostly space and energy.
If you were to take the space away from
that, from every human being in every,
every piece of material,
you could fit every human being
that's ever lived in side of baseball.
And then they started going,
well, if that's the case,
then there's gotta be a mathematical
explanation for this theoretically,
which would mean that this is some kind
of a Hologram, et Cetera, et cetera.
Leave it up to these mathematicians.
You know,
you're just got to the point when you
start getting that high math stuff,
it doesn't weigh more
fascinating, right? It's like the,
it's a mathematical model of how
universe might work,
but it doesn't tell you anything
about reality cause there's nothing,
any of that you can test it just saying
behind the curtain there might be this,
but there's no way of looking behind the
curtain. Right. There's this like with,
you know,
stupid strength theory.
You can't really test it yet because
it's based on these like tiny little
dimensions in the, in, in underneath
atoms and things like that.
So it's kind of like a
little bit meaningless. Sure.
Although wouldn't you say,
and I've heard that there,
there have been mathematical equations
that were thought up 150 years ago by
random mathematicians and it really
had no bearing on the physical world.
A hundred years later,
130 years later. Oh look,
I'm measuring the distance between quarks
and how they relate to such and such.
And in fact this equation is
incredibly applicable. Yeah.
Some types of math, like people
thought there was no use for it at all.
Like you mentioned to me numbers,
the square root of minus
one is an imaginary number.
It's not a real number. Uh,
uh, they, they didn't have
any use back in the day.
They're just Newtonian mechanics.
But now quantum mechanics uses
imaginary numbers in the math.
That's what blows my mind is the fact
that, fuck, did you just say that?
And that's what blows my mind because
in math,
oh my God, I'm so stupid yet
there yet they're practical.
Yet they haven't applied
practical application to,
to reality now because these,
these quantum scientists, the,
when they're dealing on the quantum level,
it actually,
it's actually relevant and that's what
fascinates me is somebody thinks up an
incredible mathematical equation a
hundred years ago for no reason and Lo and
behold,
he thought it up and we're using it today
because it reflects the physical world.
Just been a whole history of mathematics
that most people are completely
ignorant to me. Absolutely. I,
but I have read articles where people
who are mathematical geniuses were
describing like breakthroughs and Mac
mathematics and they look at it like,
see people look at baseball.
They look at it like people look like
the great sports heroes of the past.
Like great mathematicians.
It's like there's like this
weird sort of comradery,
this a culture of these super people
that are just concentrating on numbers.
So fucking freaky
thing.
They're in their own little world because
they've got this language that only
they can talk. They talk to other
mathematicians about things.
So you're talking about like,
I was on the bus once a back in England
and there's two guys behind me and they
were talking about 24 dimensional sphere
packing. And it started out, they said,
well,
24 dimensional spear packing.
And then after that I couldn't
understand a single word that they said.
It was just this complete gobbledygook
good.
There's a great,
NPR did an amazing documentary on this
mathematician who's name escapes me.
He was, they were just honoring him, all
these mathematicians around the world.
And they talked to this
famous mathematician and he
said, oh, he was a saint.
And a guy goes, what? He goes, he was a
saint, there's no other way to put it.
And he said, what do
you mean? He said, his,
his influence on all of us was so profound
because what he would do was he would
find out that there was a mathematician
somewhere in the world working on a very
complicated problem. And he would
show up at their door and say,
he would show up at the
door and say, uh, hello, uh,
my name is such and such and I'm here
to lend you my brain in any way I can.
And he would help the guy.
And I know it's so brilliant though.
Image of you in middle jerking off and
that guy and knocking on the door wants
to play with numbers. What the fuck are
you buddy? I don't even know each other.
Get outta here. Get outta here.
Where you crazy mass kill.
He would come up with weird ideas that
he'd see a hawk flying overhead and he'd
say,
and he'd calculate the amount of the
globe that the Hawk was able to see at any
given time or,
or when or if or if it flew for 60
minutes and he would come up with these
incredible answers where you go,
that's actually kind of it.
What's really fascinating is how
little attention we put to that,
but yet what a huge impact it has on
the reality of our world as opposed to
celebrities having babies.
Oh Em Gee,
Alec Baldwin freaked out on that.
Photog can you believe that? No,
I can't believe it.
A Guy,
he's got a temper and there's a bunch of
dudes standing in front of him when he
was with his baby taking pictures.
Yeah. I wonder why he went crazy. Yeah.
I wonder why he went after them.
That's not nearly as bizarre
as the whole picture.
Look at this world of mathematics that
allows this person to make this camera
look at this super genius had figured
out how to get this chip and break this
computer down to this tiny little
sensor and figuring out how to,
and it's all digital and you fucking
can use your finger to flip through the
images and it's this huge thing.
It just captures everything crystal clear.
That's, that's Matt. That's craziness.
Hot Chick, isn't it in a way,
but,
but the,
the main impact of it is this massive
distraction of celebrity gossip.
Okay, cool. Shit.
Because that's immediate and visceral
that anyone can relate to it.
I know, but it's weird how people can
relate to a metric to track shiny. Yeah.
But it's, it's, it's amazing how all,
I mean if you looked at like our
pie chart of what what we, uh,
pay attention to in the
world and showed math,
it would be so small.
It was this little tiny slip out of us.
Think about sex and food
and music. Your music sucks. Fucking
Twitter assholes on Twitter. You know,
again, isn't Twitter the
mechanism by which you do it?
It's an algorithm probably who wasn't
the algorithm. This is all man.
It's all benefit for sure.
And it's with the Internet would be
impossible if it wasn't for the matter.
The lack of math kind of underlies a lot
of the conspiracy theories out of that
because people don't,
they have this stopping point that they
can't get beyond because at some point
you've got to do a little
bit of math to check your,
your science or your theory or
whatever it is, right? Like with light,
the chem trail thing like Giddy,
you get this angles and geometry and
stuff like that, but people, you know,
they stopped because they can't do that.
And with other things like
we'll trade center collapsed.
There's and things like that.
There's a bit of math to do there,
but the vast majority of people can never
get past that mental barrier of having
to do a bit of math.
Yeah, well the math of how many people
would have to be in on it is a big one.
I mean you're not talking about like
people always like to use the Manhattan
project as a good example of people being
able to keep a secret for a long time,
but boy is that a different
sort of situation,
boys at a different time in the world?
Yeah,
wartime before social internet,
before a social networking programs that
we enjoy today that allow you to know
that Tommy Morrison died today and let
you get immediately, instantly that ride.
It's going to say it's very hard to get
information to people that, oh, it comes,
it comes so rapid right now.
It's just,
it's hard to believe that they would
be able to keep that a secret. That's,
that's one thing and then
it's hard to see the benefit.
Like what's what's actually being
done here? People being what,
who's actually getting hurt because
of this? Like how many more diseases?
And we really looked at the numbers.
What is, what does the MPO, oh, actually,
we're healthier now than ever before.
So what,
what are we actually looking at here?
What are we, we're looking at here.
It's like this,
this very blinder edge look
of the world where you're,
you're just choosing to focus on one
aspect of something that you're seeing and
consumes our lives as well. The picture
spreads into everything. Yeah. It's a,
it's almost a philosophy.
It's, uh, there's,
there's a philosophy to skepticism and
there's a philosophy to cynicism and I
think they're different things. And I
think a lot of people look at skeptics,
skepticism and cynicism as being equal.
And I don't think they're eating a little,
I have a bit of a problem with,
like, I used the word debunker. Uh,
rather than skeptic. A skeptic kind
of just implies all you're little,
you don't believe in stuff,
but debunkers an active thing.
You're actually going out there and
trying to do something about it.
But people think that debunk has I just
automatically disbelieving everything
which work, which is not what
not work. Debugging is about.
It's about finding things that
are wrong and then exposing them,
not starting out.
Assuming yes.
Isn't that,
isn't that the scientific method isn't
skepticism and doubt what is always the
scientist is always got to
prove. Yeah, absolutely.
I always keep doubt in his mind. Right?
So you have to be skeptical as a,
as a scientist think
the anti science people,
they think that science is a dogma
that's fixed. Whereas completely opposite
sciences is constantly changing and
constantly correcting it or all is doing
basically it's finding the things
that still are not known in science.
And what I really like about what you,
the way you do it is you're not making
any enemies while you're doing it.
You know, you're, you're being nice about
it. You're being very calm about it.
When you were in the face of
incredible stupidity when uh,
when we did our show and that guy was
creating his is fucking cloud machine was
goofy fake harp thing.
That wasn't even really hard.
It was like he is attaching an electricity
to this box and sending a current
through it and he had artificial like
those MREs for those a bonsai things that
you see at the mall. There's always
looked out but you never buy one.
You know those bonsai trees always look
sweet like Mac bonds actually in my
office, but shit, they make
noise to Gurgle, Gurgle,
shyness saw the original bonds I the
ones that have four or 500 years old.
I was a kid,
I never forgot that I went to mainland
China and they're tiny and they're four
or 500 yards yard.
Oh there are my God hear them.
They had some that were 700 year old
trees that were still tiny and they were
exactly like a 700 a hundred year
old oak or something and they were,
I couldn't get over it. I was probably,
how old was I? I was 15 years old.
I couldn't stop staring at, so they're
just constantly manicuring yeah,
there's that.
There are people who pass their gender,
their skill to generation after
generation and they raised these,
these trees and they're bonsai trees.
And Wow,
that's amazing. That's another
thing, man. It's like we,
we have it in our heads so much that
this is the way culture is like America,
like this is it.
Like this is like one possibility that
a pattern can get started and then it
follows.
It becomes a tradition.
Then it becomes your culture and
then it becomes the way you behave.
And they're radically different. I
mean boys like girls, girls like boys,
sometimes girls like girls,
sometimes boys like boys.
Other than that it's all bets are off.
People they have their,
their writing is fucking incredibly alien
that driving on the wrong side of the
street.
They have all sorts of things.
The you except as like being like
normal to you. They're like, like,
like they white,
they wipe their ass with their left hand.
Like you can't touch a dude's
left hand. Right. The Guy I had,
the guy I had on just,
I'm about to have my podcast Josh for,
I just did an interview with him and he
has been living in the Congo with hunter
gatherers, the original, the final,
probably one of the last very last people
and the deep Congo forest with pygmies.
They're all pygmies.
They come up,
toss guy comes up to his shoulders and
he had Justin wren on the podcast, who's,
you know who he is,
he's on the ultimate fighter and now he's
dedicated his entire life to help him
pygmies. He goes back and
forth there and makes films.
It makes me wonder if Josh knows
and Josh Board, but I bet they do.
I'll just pick me, help her dudes and
asked him. I asked him, what's this scary,
but he was just talking about it.
He was talking about progress and he
said the one thing we don't die of his
stupid diseases, thank God for
vaccines and antibiotics and stuff and,
and there's a lot of
death. Uh, but he said,
but then he was talking about how for
the most part they smoke I shit load of
weed by the way. Ah, yeah.
And the pygmies always high,
always hot and they spent a lot of time,
they actually,
there's a lot of food around
so they're prime murmur.
Merrily carnivores that eat some
roots and they different nuts. But um,
but there's enough food around and they
have a lot of time to hang out and said,
what are they doing?
It's just a lot of times they'll just
watch their kids run around and play.
I was like, I said, what's
the most dangerous animal?
Like a, you know, snakes.
He goes, no, no, not snakes.
You don't have to worry about
it. It's just elephants.
I was like, what do you mean?
He goes, elephants in the,
and you always sneak up on
them by accident and they
just come at you and God,
that's must be so
terrifying and intelligent.
Giant animal that's to
there. This, Justin Wren,
when the first time of these kids
had ever seen a white guy before,
and Justin's a big giant white
guy with really light skin. Wow.
They're freaking out. Justin has red hair,
right? It's like reddish brown brown.
Good on you. Justin wren.
Good on you. He's a little
ginger. Oh, he's a great guy.
He's a real sweetheart.
And uh,
he said that this really gave his life
a lot of meeting and he just feels
completely dedicated to these people.
Know that those kids, they're so sweet.
They're, well, he just exploded the way
you explained it was very pure, you know,
that he wouldn't, when he went over there
and he started helping these people,
like he had this massive sense of
helping, you know, that he could help,
that he could accomplish something,
that he could really make an impact.
I asked Josh, I said, you know, you see
a lot of death and that people die and,
and one of the things that,
one of the things that modern,
I think society has given us is we
have to bury our children a lot less
frequently than we did. Just 50 years
ago. Thank God. And I said, one,
when someone,
you know,
people who are on such an intimate
terms with life and death with a lot of
people die all the time. Uh, how do they
deal with death? And he looked at me,
he said, people are just people, man.
And they take death just
as heavily as any of us do,
regardless of how frequent it happens.
It's always, you know, a soul crusher.
I'm sure that we had this
tendency to believe, well,
you've been around it a lot and they just
accept the fact that that's a part of
reality.
But the,
the impact of it father losing their
son or mother losing or whatever, it's,
it's incredibly painful.
It's always going to be,
it's one of the main motivating factors
that people have to succeed and to
shelter themselves correctly and to
keep food on the table. You know,
you're never going to avoid that.
It's pulling America.
There'll be sheltered from, from death, I
think. Yeah, absolutely. It was spoiled.
One theory about the waterways, the
FEMA coffins, uh, which is great liners.
There's big piles of grave
liners in the field somewhere.
People say that the coffins,
that FEMA has been stockpiling a,
but they're really just like these plastic
things that they put it up of grapes.
But you know, cause people
aren't familiar with, you know,
they don't go to very many
funerals because again,
very few people die over the course of
your life until you get to be older.
All the young people I had,
they don't recognize these things cause
they don't know anything about the
burial process. So they think, oh it
must be like FEMA slot behind coffins.
Yeah.
And they'd probably listen to Alex Jones.
That wasn't Alex Jones thing.
Camps coffins lined up.
You're telling me West,
I have been to the FEMA camps.
That was good.
There's 10,000 body holds out there.
Boy,
I want to hear him hitting on a girl,
Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan is one of the most
underrated impressionist show.
If it's Alex Jones or Joey's the is and
Mike Tyson. You do a great Mike Tyson.
I haven't done that one a long time.
You do a very good Mike Tyson.
You do a great Arnold. Thank
you very much. You're sweetie.
But I am um, what, uh,
what owes the,
we sort of got a little bit sidetracked
with a Brian's awesome story of pygmies.
Sorry. It's pretty bad out. Don't
sorry. It was pretty bad ass.
But what I was getting to
was that, um, you, you don't,
you don't make any enemies
when trying to see it,
but you can't help it sometimes because
people will take just the fact that you
are explaining where they
were wrong. Right. As being,
you telling them they asked stupid. Yes.
But I would tell them they're stupid.
That's my point.
It's like you do so much better job.
Just so much better for this job than
me because as a comedian that was,
it's a real problem with like even
doing this Joe Rogan questions,
anything show or everything show,
because there was certain point
in times where as a comedian,
I couldn't just have you
stand in front of me.
Tell me you've seen something completely
retarded with no emotion attached to it.
You know, I just like, Oh really? Oh you
did. Oh did ya fucking wasting my time.
Especially asshole. I look,
I try to be really nice.
As much as I can get a lot better,
I got a lot better cause he used
to be when you were younger,
Joe would just be like, what? That's
stupid. I'm not talking to anymore.
I knew there's,
there's things that can happen in this
life that can really hold you up and one
of them,
one of the things that can complicate
and fuck your life up to no end is when
you make the mistake of allowing really
stupid people into your life because
really stupid people that not
thinking about themselves,
they're not thinking about you.
They're just thinking about filling holes,
whether it's emotional holes or
psychologicals and they're not.
They're not really even there for you.
I wish you had learned
that they're everywhere.
They're like poisonous plants that look
like the real thing. It's like if, if you,
you like it, there was a certain smell
that salary gave off and if you ate it,
it just breaks your Dick,
gives you diarrhea,
it gives you headaches or six months. You
would avoid that. Like the play. Well,
but that is the case with relationships.
It's the case with friendships.
It's the cast case with
relationships and at,
when I was young I felt like
I was fighting up river.
I felt like those motherfuckers,
these weak dummies that will get in your
life and make up stories and lie or be
mean to you or shit on you or say
things about you behind your back,
they're your enemy.
So it comes to that go through.
Cause I still learned that and I never
did nobody. Yeah, I just figured that out.
Well it wasn't entirely right.
I she's like create a lot of enemies
that didn't need to be my enemies.
There was a much more levelheaded
way of looking at it. But that took,
for me at least it took some,
I had a,
I had to develop that
understanding on my own.
I had a developed understanding or
like when to do it, when to not,
when to be kind to people and when to like
try to genuinely let someone know
that you can't listen to this anymore.
You know, like, listen, I just,
I'm sure you're a nice guy,
but here this is my take on this and
this is why I don't like discussing these
things. Whereas if I was 23 I would have
been like, dude, please shut the fuck up.
You're killing my brain.
You fucking dummy.
Don't you didn't see the
Shit I had to do that.
A couple of people will
fucking beat you down.
They will beat you down with stupidity.
They will climb inside your head and
just say a bunch of stupid shit out you.
And if you allow,
if you venture into that world,
you're going to be hanging around with
problems to solve where you get nowhere.
You're life is not going to be
like figuring out your life.
Your life is going to be dealing with
whatever emotional bullshit these morons
in your life have dragged into it.
And instead of like supporting each
other and helping each other and evolving
together,
you're in this constant weird stream
of conflict with the person that you're
friends with. Ab think he's mad at me,
man. I don't know what the fuck I did,
but you know he's got a
bug up his ass lately.
Like you know those types of people
and they start conflicts and then hey,
Bobby thinks you're mad at him. I mean
I don't know where you want to do that.
What is all that? What is, where's that
coming from? This is a pro. You get,
you let that shit into your life,
you got problems and people date that too.
Exactly.
In relationships where they,
where they're having text wars for
three hours. It's really simple.
Don't be a cunt. Don't be a
[inaudible] zone. Yeah, don't be a con.
And we could all be nice to each other,
but as soon as you allow continuous,
and this motherfucker was, he had a whole
cunt farm. He had a hole cut, a hole,
cut produce section and he was just,
he had all of these constant,
he was growing in his life
all over the place. The point,
we'd be constantly late for things
because he would always have like 15
different obligations at some asshole
that he was hanging out with. Dude, dude,
I really need you to have for me,
brother. I really need you there for me.
This is my thing. You know? Oh,
this is my first time in acting class
where I'm standing up, but I'm doing like,
and you would go to these idiots think
you would go to all those things and then
you would come to me afterwards. He was
like, you got to clean your life outside.
You got to clean your life out.
You hanging around with way too
many crazy assholes. Exhausting.
That was the best compliment you ever gave
me. He said you never needed anything.
Right. I think that's why you
hung out with me a lot, right?
Cause I just didn't need
anything from you. Oh,
you look one of my most Leeton
least needy friends I've ever met.
Nothing. You need nothing.
When I'm first met,
you didn't even have a fucking door knob.
I didn't have a door knob.
He was living in Venice in a fucking
apartment. I go upstairs. Uh,
this is his place. I pushed the door
open. I'm looking down. There's no,
there's no knob.
It's a whole.
You could look down on your knees and
look right into his apart. I father,
I said that to me. My father saw the car
was driving. That goes, hey, he goes up,
I can afford to buy you a nicer car you
want me to do. I'll do it right now.
I was like, man, I'm all right.
Now what I recognize when I met you was
this guy who is like almost like you're
trying to save people from
the thing that you would be.
You would least like you're to find
yourself in that sort of a position.
I think that's good. You were,
you were looking at them.
If they were you and you didn't feel
entirely secure growing up and you felt
like as a good person that you are,
you would just cha cha,
try to help these guys out. He's
a good guy, just got a bath.
He's got a crazy idea
project for me yesterday.
The idea of how and
bring them in otherwise,
but the beautiful thing about you do this,
first of all,
we never argued about these things.
Like when you had a crazy
person in your life,
you were more than willing to listen
you you like we disagreed about a few of
them but you never got like shitty about
it and I think you're a really logical
thinking.
You always have been and so like you
looking back on all your behavior so
fascinating because you're looking
at it like a science project.
Like oh this is why I was doing this
here and this is why it was a silly goose
right there and right.
The amount of time I wasted just just
buying two parrots and having two dogs and
moving a complete lunatic into my house.
You know, I just, I would like, let's see,
well let's see.
Everything's going well.
Let me see how I can complicate
the shit out of this.
Maybe I can buy a chimp while I'm at it.
You know, it just, you do, you do a lot.
It's a lot of, it's just self
sabotage in a way. It is,
but that the logical
thinking that you have it,
what's fascinating about it and how it
applies to debunking things and you've
always been really good at that or really
a energetic about it, you know, um,
is that when you have like this way of
thinking that you sort of cultivated over
a lifetime of watching people
fuck up left and right around you.
You can sometimes see other people's
problems better than you can even see in
your own. And so you see that and he'd
go, oh, no, no, no, no, no, that's this.
You're looking at this like, it's like,
well, what you really want to be do?
It's like turn inward and figure out
why the fuck you're doing the weird shit
that you're doing and your
life in the first place.
And once you started doing that,
your life completely turned around.
You got rid of all the cuckoo heads in
your life and then your career started
taking off and then you realize,
oh,
I was distracting myself and that was
holding me back. Wow. I didn't know.
What I find most fascinating
about that when it, when you,
when you apply that to like debunking
is that there's no god damn guidebook to
living life.
And when you're going through life and
you're trying to figure the whole thing
out and trying to be a good person and
trying to follow the laws and succeed and
get ahead, nobody really can
tell you how the fuck to do it.
And a lot of times people feel like
there's forces holding them down.
There's a lot of times people feel like,
man, if I was just in with that crowd,
then I would know if I was just with the
hell. It's all nepotism, it's all the,
it's,
it's a crazy scary system that
we're filtering our bodies through.
That's what it really is.
And so there's a lot of perceived shit
out there that's really internal shit and
that's one of the issues.
It's causing people to look at whatever
it is that they want to believe is real.
Whatever crazy area,
51 conspiracy theory they want to pull
all their time into like why are you
really doing that?
Is it really because the evidence is
overwhelming or is there a psychological
issue at stake here?
Is there something going on that
you're trying to not think about?
Is that what's causing you?
And you know what,
most of them admit it's the great demise.
Most of them are met.
It's a midlife crisis thing. They were
honest about it. Really. A big foot guys.
And I went out, went,
cause it gives me space,
part of this small community of believers.
Well,
the big foot guys were super
cool and really nice guys.
And one of the things the guy said, they
were really fun. Like they weren't dumb.
They're just really fun,
interesting guys who believe in Sasquatch
and they're like going and looking for
him. But the guy was like, even
if it's not real or camping. Yeah.
And it was any hint joy man. He
enjoyed it. He was a cool guy. Yeah.
And Randy talked about
modern art, uh, enthusiasts.
So they'd come and see Rauschenberg,
like a, a broom in a, in a bucket.
And he'd sell it for
$200,000 and she said,
they're not here for
art than I even heard.
They are here to be part of a very small
elite group of people that actually can
quote unquote appreciate such as
such sort of obscure expression.
Yeah.
I think there's a big difference though
between like big foot and say Cantrell's
in nine 11. Because if you're,
if you're wrong about bigfoot,
there's no no big deal. You just like,
you know, weren't right but big foot.
But if you're wrong about
nine 11 or chem trails,
then your entire world
view comes crashing down.
So I think people are much more invested
mentally in things like the most
serious conspiracy theories and the
origin, the supernatural and things.
Yeah, I do believe your
ride being invested mentally
is a great way to put it.
It works. This works both ways as
well. Like debunkers and skeptics.
Some of them get kind of obsessed with a,
with deep on King and people start out,
like as young people, young
people debunking, they uh, uh,
they just knock things down one at a time.
They see something that's wrong and
they're not stupid or like, you know, Oh,
let me explain that.
And they're not really,
they're not really being very productive.
And that's something I thought about a
lot as as I've been doing it for more and
more years, is you couldn't figure
it out. You know, what's the,
what's the long term goal here?
Just like telling one guy that
he's wrong and explain to one guy,
he's not really very useful,
but if you couldn't look at what you're
actually doing and try to improve the
way you're communicating with with these
people and try to reach a broader set
of people than just doing it as a sport,
which is kind of what a lot
of people who are skeptics do,
they do it because they enjoy it.
They get this,
this visceral thing like, yeah, this
year from proving, proving people wrong,
that creates a competition sort of feel.
Yeah.
And it creates a lot of animosity and
that's what I was really crediting with
you,
that you do a great job of avoiding that.
You just talked to them like
extremely rationally. I mean,
the guy that we were talking about that
did this harp experiment seemed like a
nice guy. Yeah, he did. This is, this is
how easy, it seemed like a very nice guy.
I really enjoyed his company.
It not, I'm not a bad guy
at all. And he's obviously a
smart guy too. Um, but his friend,
when I go into his office,
I walk in the door,
they have a picture of this Indian guy,
he's got a white beard and he's got
white paint on his face and he's, uh,
he's kind of a, a portly fellow, like a
and a, I go, who's that guy? And he goes,
well,
10 years ago he underwent an incredible
transmogrification or some shit like
that of his body,
and now he no longer needs water or food.
And I go, oh, he didn't rent the Tarion.
Yeah, exactly. And I just go, no,
he didn't. And he goes, no,
you really have to meet up. I
go, no, I don't. No, I don't.
I can't. But that's where, that's
where everything shuts down.
Like I have to go stop.
There's never been a person,
they've even proven to be
able to survive a week.
Do you know that without a week with
no water and no food, you're gone,
son. You can't live active. Figured
that out. Like you're not magic, right?
You fucking fat shit
white paint on your face,
that outrageous. You think the
burden of proof would be on them?
I mean that you can't just say that to
me. He said you have to meet him. The I'm,
I'm denying meeting him because
I'm a government chill and a,
that's the whole reason why we can't
prove to the world on Joe Rogan questions.
Everything that there are real
breadth of Tarion's. Right?
You get the fuck out of here. God
Damn it. It's like there's not,
there's not elves to what I
would like it to be Elvis.
It's like I watched this
guy reading is great.
You had a loved it and there's that.
We're at this cafe and this beautiful
girl is there and there's this guy,
this middle aged guy,
and he's reading her palm and clearly
he is her healer or whatever. Oh yeah.
And I just said I was with
two other people and I go,
that guy's, that guy's, oh,
you want to see a scam artist right
there, right there. There's a scam artist.
Right. They're trying to get laid
by reading her palm, and he was,
he was obviously a professional like,
you know, I could tell him about,
he was talking, she was asking him
questions. What does that mean?
How do you know he's a scumbag?
I go, because he's a liar.
That's why he's making a living that way.
Well, you can just tell, you know, if you
ever got your palm read, it's nonsense.
Yeah. Yeah. They just start talking
about your lifeline and you,
what you went to here onto one of those
places. It's open like 24 hours a day.
It's just like the lady lives there and
then you just ring the doorbell and she
wakes up and it's so depressing. I went
there once drunk with a friend. Oh,
like God.
I felt like I just woke up somebody
at their house and now they're just,
I have to talk to him. I went to one in
New York. I was on my way to an audition.
I had some time. I really didn't like
acting back then anyway, and a saw,
I went to this a Tarot card
reader ladies place and uh,
she was wrong about everything.
I mean, could not be wrong.
I don't even bother debunking stuff like
that, I think. But it was beautiful.
It was.
It was because I never knew my grandmother
was like always fancied herself a
psychic. My, Oh yeah. My
grandmother is completely crazy.
Like Sylvia Brown makes $700 for,
for 20 minute consultation.
And my grandmother had a monkey
is a big scam. She had a monkey.
She rarely got a monkey. Yeah.
Monkey's was cheeky. Monkey bite
everybody. Okay. She was the only
way to get hold on to this monkey.
That's so crazy. My grandmother was,
she lived in a haunted house. Right.
It was a haunted house because there was
a dude, they were renting a room too,
and the guy died and then he
just kept showing up, you know,
even after he was dead. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Weird House in North Ninth
Street that they live,
that they bought during the Italian
period when all the immigrants were coming
over.
So they got it.
Like when my grandfather was working
for the factories are making the atomic
bomb parts. Everybody was just talk about
that, you know, grandpa makes it part.
They using in the atomic bomb. I thought,
wow, my grandpa's making the bomb.
That's how fucking crazy people
were back then. But uh, this house,
this neighborhood,
while they were living there constantly
changed and got worse and worse and
worse. They did blockbusting they
move people in and said, hey listen,
black people are moving in.
You better sell now.
And they would sell up giant chunks of
real estate at a fraction of what they're
worth. Just through the scare
tactics. And my grandfather was like,
I like black people. I'm
not going anywhere. And he
stayed. And because of that,
their,
their whole neighborhood like completely
changed and became really scary and
dangerous like North Ninth Street right
now where they leveled their house.
They died a few years back,
but it was a really bad neighborhood
by the time they were gone.
I'm like really bad. So, you know,
a lot of people were seeing shit.
What's that sound like?
Fucking Christ on edge all the time.
My grandmother already was crazy and
she already had a monkey, you know,
and if you are over that house,
and I lived there for a while.
When I first came to New York, I
didn't have any money. And uh, I,
when I got signed by my manager, I had
to leave my apartment, uh, travel, uh,
by car all the way to New York.
And I didn't have enough money to save
up for an apartment because I was only
making like a couple hundred bucks a week.
Right.
Like doing gigs when I
first moved to New York.
So I stayed with my grandfather in this
terrible neighborhood in North Ninth
Street in Jersey, in Newark.
And while I was there,
you'd hear sirens in the middle of
the night. The next door neighbor,
they broke down his house with a battering
ram cause he was selling crack. Yeah.
The week, week or two weeks before I
got there. This was all like fenced off.
There's yellow tape and shit.
It was like, it was crazy.
That was his next door neighbor.
It was,
and he knew that that kid
that became the drug dealer,
he knew that kid from
the time he was a baby.
So he got to like experience this
generational to becoming this,
you know, 20 year old drug dealer with
an Audi parked in his, uh, you know,
like a little driveway area in, in
Newark, unbelieving it talent. But it was,
it was crazy,
but you would feel like it was haunted
cause it was just so dangerous.
It was crackling. So everybody was
always like, this house is haunted.
And my grandmother was like, I knew
that was gonna happen. She always,
any other way the, it looks like
I told Ted, scary old house.
Kids will think it's haunted. And then
you just say natural thing doing this, um,
this show,
the Joe Rogan questions,
everything show I got to meet this guy
bandit check who's a mentalist. Did you,
do you know what guys? Yeah.
Holy Shit. Is this guy good?
What do you mean mentalist? He, well, he
tells you right away I'm bullshitting you.
Okay.
This is all tricks,
but I'm going to show you how I tricked
scientists and believing that I actually
had psychic for four years and he did,
I mean,
he's a master mentalist who puts
on shows like he entertains,
like sort of like Penn and
teller type style. Yeah. So dude,
I had a dollar bill in my pocket. I
pulled the dollar bill out. This is,
we took coins, put them
over his eyes. Okay.
And then duct tape over the coins and
I'm holding the dollar bill here and he's
reading the serial number,
the dollar bill that came from my pocket.
I know where the dollar bill came from
because it was an afterthought to put it
in my pocket.
I grabbed my keys and there was like a
five and a one sitting next to my keys.
I go,
I'll let me get that too.
And then I just stuffed it in my pocket
and left the house. And so when he said,
can you pull a bill out of your pocket?
I knew the,
it was a rare moment
where I knew the exact,
like the history of that
dollar bill for the day.
I knew he didn't get ahold of it.
No one had placed it in my pocket.
Maybe he sleight of hand in your pocket.
You don't think I'd be able to feel a
man's hands that close to my bedtime.
Like a leopard, bro. You can't just
touch me like that and touched me there.
I watched a to what it was waging a
hunting show me just say this right now,
when you talk about leopard swimming
and a deer got hit by an Arrow and deers
are so fucking fast as the
Arrow is going through its body,
it turned to get away and so it wound
up shooting through the top of its body.
Yeah.
And these shows it in the video how it
happened and he's like sometimes like
deers, defy science. Unreal
man. It's a magic bullet.
But you read the serial
number on the dollar.
You were the serial number
on my fucking dollar bill.
I have no idea how he
did it. He, he would,
he did a bunch of different things like
twisting a fork, but it's all tricks.
He tells you. He's like, I am not magic.
I don't have psychic powers. He goes,
I'm just really good at tricking you.
Yeah. Well the good thing was
when he did that, the scientists,
he actually went into this
scientific study with another
guy, uh, for about Metta,
several, several months. And there was
these scientists who are trying to,
there was studying ESP and they did
all these tests on these two guys,
but the two guys were actually the
magicians that were bantered checking this
other guy. And so they were basically
fooling the scientists, the scientists,
and you don't like writing these
papers about these like amazing guys.
And they did all these,
these tests like where they would,
they would seal things up.
So there was no way that a,
the check could actually get inside it,
but he would figure out a way of getting
inside the thing and like bending the
wire then putting it back. So no one
could tell because he's a magician.
He knows like I have to
get dodgy stuff like that.
And he completely fill
them for several months.
And they were writing all these things
in these academic journals about how that
actually discovered ESP and
how they'd been replicating it.
But it was all this thing set up by, uh,
by James Randy who was, uh, you know,
he's really an old time skeptic. Go who
debunked a Uri gala and people like that.
I know that guy. Yeah.
Yeah. We'll go with a beard.
Yeah. He's a fascinating cat. And um,
the whole skeptic versus psychic movement
or a debate is a very interesting one
as well. I did, um, an episode we
went to the Rhine Institute and we,
you know, did all the uh, you know the
Rhine Institute for Psychic Studies,
something when it is,
it's a,
it's a really interesting setup where
they have all these ancient methods that
they used to use to try to figure out
whether or not someone had psychic powers.
The ability to pick which color
light is going to turn on next,
the ability I failed all of them failed
everything have zero psychic power,
fucking zero.
But then there was a scene where I had
to go into this dark room and try to
generate energy and a, I
was like, okay, like what?
Like there's this or there's a guy named,
I think his name was ed and Ed
knew how to get it up to a million,
which is higher than a CI masters.
Like they had all this and all this
crazy talk about your body being able to
generate light. So mine is very
hot. My reading is very high.
But I take into consideration what
I was doing afterwards and I'm like,
I was wearing a battery pack.
Like, how has that, that's not it.
That's like the least scientific
way of measuring light.
I mean I have a fucking
thing that has a light in it.
Even if you can cover the light with
a piece of tape, which they did.
And even if you put the light under a
shirt, if I'm fucking stretching around,
what are the odds of some light
peeking out there and sell equipment?
What kind of sites?
Yeah,
it could actually prove this stuff.
They would be winning Nobel prizes cause
it's like completely changed science.
And then they claim that they have this
proof and there's evidence that they can
do detecting like ESPN stuff.
But when the push comes to shove,
they actually come.
I, you know what, man, I've
never seen anyone who can do it,
but I can't believe that I know the
extent of the capabilities of all human
beings. There's people that have
some really bizarre intuitive skills.
There's people that uh,
no danger better than other people
check doing this stuff.
He's a
guy, by the way, he grew up in
a very, very dangerous time.
He grew up in South Africa. He was raising
his kids, his brothers and sisters,
I believe by himself. I don't know
if I keep grew up like a street kid.
Right. And that's, that's
experienced human beings are really,
really good at pattern recognition.
So they did lots of studies
with the Swat Team Guy,
a veteran swat team guy and then they
took a rookie cop and and the veterans,
they have a guy just
walking up to a school,
a up to a school with a bomb pack to his
body and behaving in a certain way and
when they'd simulate it,
the Swat team guys shoot him way earlier
cause the Swat team guy was able to
pick up immediately something was wrong
with this guy. He wasn't a regular guy,
was a twitch in his arm or whatever.
And he recognize patterns over years
and that's what he was good at.
So human beings get,
Ken can develop what would be a peer to
be psychic powers because they pick up
out and recognition and pick
up on signals way beforehand.
Like guy who trains grizzly bears or
lions. He was telling me, he said,
I don't get bit because the
lion of the grizzly bear,
if he's in an irritable mood,
is going to tell me three minutes
beforehand when he's going to attack and
people that don't know animals,
the ones that get attacked,
he said when a grizzly bears
having a hard time with you,
he'll start clicking his jaw.
The minute he, his jaw training
sessions over baby that it's done.
And lions are the same way.
They start giving you signals
way, way before, and they're
subtle signals, but you,
if you don't know how to read them,
you're in big trouble.
If you do know how to read them, step off
so you're not a horse whisperer bitch.
It seems like the reading the
mind like mine reading of the bed,
it's just the very well
boasting in Beth psychology.
Cesar Milan guy,
that guy kicks dogs.
We've ever seen him kicked dogs.
Yeah, like this with the nines.
Not that I'm thinking there's
anything wrong with kicking some dogs,
but he checks him hard dude. But I'm
saying is he's very good at training dogs.
And I'm not saying that
what he does is wrong.
What I'm saying is he ain't psychic.
He's not whisper nice fucking dogs right
now. He does. He tells people all the
time, cause you got to keep to yourself.
He said, yes, I'm here to train
you. I'm not hearing the dog's fine.
Dog tries to bite people and
attacks don't reflection.
It's actually you're the problem too.
Like when you talk to talking about
your friend who's like a sniper,
I bet you had,
there's sort of certain
pattern recognition to people
that are experiencing a
massive dump of adrenaline. I
go the the, the way they move,
there's probably an erratic nature to
the movement of a person who's, you know,
literally at death's door. That's, that's
gotta be an insanely intense experience.
And I bet if you've seen
that from a person and you're
like, oh Jesus, you know,
you see like a guy who was high on the
adrenaline of about being about to do
something.
Yeah.
I mean if you're looking at a guy was a
suicide bomber or something along those
lines, like could you
imagine what that the sweat,
they train the TSA to look
for those signs. Oh yeah,
and it's really better to look
then those fucking cracks.
He's cracked scientists and detective
crack commandos. Those, those people.
A Johnny on the spot at the TSA job. If
you've seen this line attack video. Yes.
Yeah. Have you put it on if you want.
I think it's pretty fucked up, right?
I've seen it.
Mall. Yeah. They fuck this guy up
and look at the girl holds the ground.
The girl is the only thing I saved
this ditch. That guy got fucked up.
Oh my God.
They're squirting them with a hose
and pointing him with sticks. Yeah,
you have to. I know, but the
fuck else did they have to man,
that's their gig. Bitch. You're fired.
Hindsight. The fight to
the, you know what, man,
I don't believe that line should be held
in captivity. I agree with you on that.
I certainly don't believe that they should
be held in captivity and forced to do
tricks.
I think that's utter total bullshit.
Stupidity,
insanity.
I think if you want to keep them in
large preserves where they can roam free,
that's one thing, but guess
what? Feed them animals.
If you're going to have them
somewhere in any form of, Oh shit.
That is terrifying. Man. Really has.
Yeah. Now they'd liked doing that. Now
they found out fun. That can be, yeah,
that's right. Your food. Oh my God.
Lions going be pushed so far, man.
Look at that too. Gfe fucked up.
Oh my God.
This is such an insane place to be
poking a stick at fucking lions.
Oh,
he got jacked again.
Oh my God.
What a nightmare must be for those people.
You got to get out. Boy. That shit girl.
She's pulling her brown and the
lines aren't fucking with her man.
He must be the bad guy. Yeah.
These guys must be dicks
cannot have that case. That's total
speculation and very rude of me to,
I should say guys getting attacked by
animals. I'm adding insult to injury.
Why we wouldn't him up. I Dunno. I'm
just being silly. I don't mean anything.
I'm saying trying to be entertaining,
but it's kind of like that movie zookeeper
that you were in jail when that one
guy was being mean to the gorilla. I
remember. Yeah. That's sort of the Cliche,
right?
Sort of like the evil stepmother. Right.
You know that the, the zookeepers,
we're always Dick's to the animals.
There's always ones who keep a
realism like animals. You as, sorry.
Yeah. This span of check cat, um,
he blew my mind and really changed the
way I look at a lot of what I thought was
like psychic stuff and I really,
really set into my head.
I still leave open the door for things
that I don't have the abilities that I
don't possess.
I don't know.
I don't know if we've completely
explored the boundaries of,
of human possibility.
And I also don't know if what is possible
today is going to be with the possible
five years from now or 10 years from now.
I think that if human beings got to
this point through adaptation, through,
you know, natural advantage, we got to
all the things that we possess. You know,
the ability to see,
touch and feel and hear and smell.
Why would I assume that there wouldn't
be some sort of new thing that comes
after that? I think if he does come,
he's going to be meditation. Yes.
It's not going to be from evolution.
It's going to be good because actually
modifying our bodies to gate implant.
We'll give you telepathy.
It could be, you know,
there was an article that I tweeted,
yes,
there was an article I tweeted
about Google that was like, you,
you're going to be able
to have an implant.
There are ultimate goal of the Google
glass is to be able to have an implant and
when you have a thought in your mind
stated that is their stated goal.
That's right. That's right. Yeah.
People are evolving themselves.
It's like normally pollution has
stopped for humans. Right, but let me,
let me take it from a different angle.
Isn't that also natural evolution and
natural evolution by a human being
augmenting his body with artificial
technology is still a part of the actual
evolution of the species is just figured
out how to bypass the normal slow steps
of the biological genetic evolution.
It's an eight some shit
with the imagination,
the imagination that lives
inside the biological entity
news, its own limitation.
I think it's an inevitable consequence
of like intelligent species are solving
but it's,
it's completely different but then again
it's still is another path that was
taken by nature the same way a be
making a beehive got to happen.
It's sort of like a natural
want to tweak.
This gives an amazing talk about it on
ted.com about how when they invent an
artificial eye that can see a mile away,
see during the night and
it's biocompatible and an
ear that does the same thing
and a Nano Bot the size
of red blood cells.
You're going to use those things and
we are going to mesh with machines way
sooner than we will ever evolve.
It's coming. Yeah, and I bet the
first thing is going to be dicks.
It's going to be artificial. There's
no doubt you're going to be s you know,
and I haven't been able to figure that
out yet to be able to figure it out.
Erections, he'd been able to figure
out Rogaine keeping some of your hair.
There's a few things are still working on,
but if soon as they could figure
out a way to actually grow dicks,
that's it because that's how you're
going to do that with their doing with
breasts.
There's studies right now going,
they're cloning how to manipulate tissue
so that the woman will grow natural
breasts with stem cells I think.
Yeah,
well I don't know the
exact a process work guys,
but they're going to try to figure
out, yeah, I guess I got it.
Gross. Some tips to these guys, these
training transgenders. Yes. Good boy.
Good cat are going to be have some great
titties, Sunni and maybe extra dicks.
I think that also there
we're going to be a full,
like complete x,
y chromosome woman, like as much of
a full complete woman as you can get.
Like they'll be able to
genetically engineer a vagina.
They won't have to be some sort of a
thing that you're making out of a penis.
In the future. You're going to be, uh,
like you might have still keep your
chromosomes. It might still be an x,
y chromosomes, but you will essentially
be 100% female in every way.
So would you hit it like if, if she had
the best pussy, the best real issue,
it'd be a real issue. Well, you
know, Progressive Society, right?
I'd like you to admit that that
is a real woman, right? Asshole.
And they would say that asshole, she is
a real woman. If she became a real woman,
would you hit it? She is a real
woman asshole. Yeah. Those,
there is a thing genetically a man.
But you know, they're not the, the,
the progressive opinion is that you're,
you shouldn't even have to divulge that.
You used to be a man. That's
your medical history, warrior
princess. And I'm having him on my
podcast, her on my podcast, Kristin Beck,
who was Chris back who was a member
of seal team six Dev grew, uh,
and a and fascinating book
because he was all she but,
but when she was a, he, uh,
always felt like a girl always and goes
into why he thinks that's the case.
Some of it had to do with
the way he was raised,
but also it was just the way he felt.
AndG and literally as,
as when he was even a very small kid,
was always stealing his sister's clothes
and wearing them and just always felt
like woman joins the seal teams in seal
team six to push what he calls his inner
girl down.
Come back after training.
It would roar back in full like a TB back
for two months. He'd be on a sailboat,
dress like a woman every single day.
And this is a elite commando,
a decorated war hero. And by the way,
a war veteran by the, by the way. Yes.
And also had done 13 deployments and I
believe still works for the Department of
Defense now that he's Kristin Beck. Can't
wait to get her on my podcast to talk.
That was another extended plug.
It was not [inaudible] she taught you
son of a bitch number one and two by the
way. Yeah, I ended plugged
us point Brian Talent show.
It's on the iTunes. That's right. But, but
the point is that it was when, when you,
when you read this book and you realize
how strong the urge to be a woman was
and then she went ahead and
got this whole operation,
which is a major thing and by the way,
and took so much flak for it. I,
you know, in a way, I mean it just,
it was something, she just have
Jewish black jacket. What's that?
Perhaps you'd get her a flak jacket.
It was real protective from flack from,
thank you. I'm going to open with that
this weekend. And Bria, that was a plug.
See, that's how you do a plug.
That's good. I won't, I will.
I will not be opening with that
when I'm in Raleigh, North Carolina.
And I would never,
I would've never guessed to know
what goes on inside someone's body.
If someone tells me they were born a
woman and they really are a man who the
fuck.
Let me ask you to tell them.
That's not the case.
But here's my question to you is you
have to say this MMA fighter, uh, who,
who is now has gotten this,
this sex change. But yeah,
I've talked to Matt, I kept
so many times and I've also been in
like enraging Twitter discussions with
people. You know, I have
to go through the, my,
my feeling is I absolutely support
anyone who wants to be a transgender,
but I think there is a real
issue with combat sports.
I don't necessarily believe that there
has been enough studies done that show
that the male frame, it's not a
significant advantage to have the male,
the mechanics of the different shape tips,
there's far less likelihood
of ACL injuries for men
just be because of the shape
of the hips.
And these are small issues.
A big one is reaction time
in measurable reaction time.
Men have shown a 10% 10% faster reaction
time almost across the board with the
lead athletes. Wow. 10% faster than women.
That's a big issue with striking a
really big issue and even though they're
swimming that can get to a skill
level that will overcompensate that.
I think that alone seems to me,
unless you can replicate that somewhere,
uh, healthfully for,
for women, like it was,
if there was something that women could
take that would bring their natural
reaction levels to where a man is that
I don't think it can ever be safe.
I think if a guy's an elite guy and a
girls and elite girl and the guy has a one
10th of a second quicker reaction time,
that's gigantic.
So that alone, and this is not an a
transphobic argument to me because I'm,
it's completely open minded as you can be.
I try very hard to look at things.
Everybody's different point of view and
I have zero issue with anyone wanting to
change their gender. Zero. I
think I'll call you a woman.
You know,
my issue only lies in combat sports
cause I just don't think it's fair.
And you know, there was an
argument in a good one in fact,
that I've considered as well
that several people have said,
well what about women who are naturally
more aggressive or naturally have more
testosterone?
Like Serena Williams who's a natural
one but a really big powerful athlete.
It's a very good point because there's,
there's women that are not going to be
able to compete with her physically if
they have the same skills, you know,
the same level of technical proficiency.
Pete, with her, the same argument
they were talking about where one,
I think it was more as Korean.
Maurice Greene has an inordinate number
of amount of testosterone in this blood
naturally occurring,
whereas another sprinter does not.
So then nature is unfair in that sense.
Certainly. I'm so, so now where's that?
So if he has 300 mil, whatever milligrams,
I don't know how to measure it,
but say 300 parts per million and the
other guy has a hundred parts per million,
what would it be acceptable for
him then to take hormone test
question?
Yeah,
it's a good question and that's a
question that's actually recently been
proposed by MMA fighters that are saying,
well listen,
if these people are on
testosterone replacement therapy,
everybody should be allowed to be on it.
As long as your levels are
the same like your your,
because these people are taking t
the look. If they have an issue,
they're taking testosterone.
It's jacking them up to a very high level
that very few people maintain at their
age limit,
but that's the acceptable limit.
That's not very scientific to me because
I feel like there's always going to be
people that have a natural
level that's very high,
that gets beaten down during training
and it's not going to care the same way
and the person that's using
indogenous chemicals, so that's,
there's an issue with that.
There's an issue that I think is
not been fully completely resolved.
That's why sanctioning is by a state,
by state basis, a case by case basis.
It's not like testosterone replacement
therapy is not like uniformly accepted
across the board. In fact, in
some places like a fighter's,
if I had to go and fight
like a in Winnipeg, um,
I'm pretty sure Rashad Evans who was
on it had to get, or not Rashad Evans,
excuse me,
Dan Henderson who was on it had to get
off of it because they wouldn't allow him
to take testosterone replacement and and
finding Canada now so that the UFC has
a limit to what your testosterone,
the UFC,
it's the state with UFC is just to promote
her. We are not the athletic bodies,
so the Nevada state athletic commission,
they look at things that way,
but I think like scientifically we have
to agree that it's a real issue as far
as a performance enhancer.
It's very significant. It's,
it gives you a significant advantage.
And then also you have to realize what's
next when they do have these nanobots
nanobots I like I said that it's like,
when you say Afghanistan cost,
there's no new boats when they do have
these things and you're taking a mic and
just so he could hold your breath at
the bottom of a pool and make a youtube
video for five hours,
you know,
that's what they're gonna be able to do
according to Ray Kurzweil. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, well, who would,
who wouldn't take that?
What are you crazy about the Olympics
too and when you got to swim or who
doesn't have to lift his head and
he showers for it? We shattered at,
but I think that in the
idea of keeping sport pure,
you can't hold back to evolution.
And there's an evolution
that we don't want to accept.
It's a symbiotic evolution of humans
and technology to create the new human.
You know, it's, it's fucking
happening whether you like it or not.
Samsung has a new watch now that
tells you how fast your heart rate is,
all the shit that's going on.
How many calories you burn hill each
day syncs up to your smart phone. Yeah.
How long before that things just embedded
in your skin, you know, how long,
how long before they, they'd take your
ear, your shitty designed ear. Oh,
you got an earache.
How about we replace it with this carbon
fiber thing that can hear on the moon?
It's calming. It's calming. And
if if you say no, you're stupid,
you just as stupid as someone who
doesn't get their bone bone fixed,
when it breaks, it's going to come with
its own challenges, that's for sure. Oh,
absolutely.
Just like everything else we've ever
done in life has come with challenges.
I think the big thing is when we, uh, we,
we get aging addressed by these doctors
and people start living like a hundred
to 200 years.
Yes. That'd be a big problem.
And that's not far away
than 50 year old man has
already been born. Uh,
first hundred days a are
likely person. Yeah. It's,
to me it's absolutely and
completely fascinating.
This incredible time of change and this
incredible time of possibility. The,
the openings are just so much greater
now than they've ever been before.
As far as the possibility for change,
a giant waves of change that will make
the world almost impossible to comprehend
to us right now as it's freakish,
as the Internet is for us today.
I think what's going to be next in the
next four or 500 years is going to blow
all this away. If we manage to stay alive,
we managed to not blow ourselves up.
I think they're going to
resolve so many issues.
Environmental issues, social
issues, the the, the, the,
the structure of society, the,
the, the way we distribute money,
all these things are there.
An echo of a shitty,
ignorant time and we're stuck with a lot
of really crummy fucking infrastructure
and a really crummy system of doing things
and a really crummy representation of
the humans that are living on this planet.
As far as the distribution of resources,
the acclamation of accumulation of wealth,
I think we're going to figure all that
out in the future. It may be three,
four generations from now, but when
we figure out all our social shit,
if we figure out that at the same time
they figured out a way to actually use
pollution for energy,
keep the world clean with technology.
That's something that people don't look
at as a possibility that a technology
though, he's going to go
ahead of the social change,
so you're going to get
this new technology,
but you're going to have the same old
social structures that you had before and
that's going to create this huge complex.
Where are you going to have this kind of
a technological elite to be still going
to have these masses of people
who are just in the old ways?
It could be,
but I don't think it has to be.
I think there's a very distinct feeling
that I get from Oh from communicating
with people over the last
few years that people,
more people are paying more attention
to the way the world is run than ever
before. More people are getting
more sensitive about inequality.
Then I feel like I felt in a long time,
Steven Pinker's book said that in the
two thousands less people were killed
violently than at any time in our history.
So there and another guy wrote a book
called the rational optimist to be read
that in a very good book. Matt Ridley, I
think his name and to um, same idea, just,
just where we're headed there is there
is progress that the way you're talking
about more sort of,
uh,
I guess transparency and people not as
ignorant people at least having more
access to information.
Yeah.
I don't think there's any evidence that
points that people are going to continue
to remain ignorant in the face of so
much access to information that we have
today. I mean, it's just the, this
is a completely different world.
The kids that are born in the last three
or four years are growing up in a world
that we couldn't even fucking imagine.
My little kid knows how to go on to
iTunes and order more points for the game
that she likes. She's five. I was
thinking of how to go to Itunes,
add in this mommy, what's your password?
Dik Dik dik dik dik she's fucking five.
You know, when you try to follow
the thread, if you were to,
if you were to say in seven generations,
it feels like we're being pushed to
move beyond our basic biology. Yes.
That's what it feels like.
And so,
so if you were to able to download
information into one's brain or even
reversed,
download the information in your brain
into something as we were talking about,
um, then the question
becomes to what end is that?
I've been trying to follow that thread.
Why, what, what goes on? Say we are,
cause you, if you could tap into a
neural net, have virtual experiences,
what it is to be someone else, uh, and,
and we just get nudged closer and closer
together in this sort of one sort of
mind, if you will. Which I
think is not far fetched.
I mean it's kind of where
we're headed now is editable.
I can do standup now and you
know, uh, California in New York,
it's kind of the same audience. It
used to be very, very different. We're,
we're starting to,
you know,
you can go do stand up and
you just go selfish with that.
I did talking about the unification.
All tire stand up dude and you're
talking to audiences to Raleigh,
North Carolina. No son of
a bitch. No, but are you,
but I wonder then what do you
think is the end result though?
What do you think is where to,
where are we going with that?
The theory is like the singularity is
that all of humanity and it'll technology
with combined into this one thing,
but I think it's going to be a remarkable
set of circumstances that would have
to happen for that to come about.
I think it's inevitable.
I think that remarkable set of
circumstances is inevitable.
We're not going to stop if it takes
five years or 500 years, I don't know.
I don't know how long it's going to tank,
but if innovation continues
to move forward in the same
exponential exponential
rate of progression that it's shown
below the plummet. He said, well,
I don't like that.
It's just that that's
one.
The other ones that are way bigger are
the natural ones like the hundreds of
thousands of near Earth objects that could
be fucking zooming at us 45,000 miles
an hour from behind the sun and those
things are going to slam into us. Again,
it's happened before. It was a lot of
recent information that shows that uh,
more than 10,000 years ago there was a
a series of major impacts all throughout
the world.
They found volcanic glass all throughout
Asia and Europe that indicates meteor
showers.
They got that Clovis comment that they've,
they've now confirmed hit that
somewhere around 12,500 years ago.
These are like not that big a
gap between us in that, yeah,
that's not that long ago,
12,000 years ago there was like some
extinction events like North America was
wiped out. Like that's happened and it's
just some shit that comes out of the sky
climate change. They're just, yes,
that's going to be a slow death of
civilization if slow death of Miami.
That's for function. As a skeptic, are
you, I'm a believer in global warming.
You hear a lot of people saying,
well,
the science behind is
really solid that there is,
there has been warming over the last a
hundred years and man is behind it. Uh,
so the question is like, you
know, what do you do about it?
Yeah, that gets obscured with the, um,
the argument that it's a natural
cycle because that's true.
There is a natural cycle of heating,
cooling and there have been times before
people like the ice age when you know,
North America had a mile high sheet
of ice, a part of it, you know,
there was a big chunk of this country,
there was a glacier,
but that maybe have changed without human
interaction or human intervention or
human causation.
But that doesn't mean that this is like
the idea that just because the earth's
temperature fluctuates doesn't
mean that we don't influence it.
Like it's pretty obvious we influence it.
You'd have to be crazy to fly above the
city and look at how many fucking planes
are criss crossing this guys and how
much smog is down there and you fly over
cities and see the pollution. To think
that's having no impact is just silly.
Yeah.
It's just silly.
And when it was saying that
about the science being solid it,
so maybe think of what I said earlier
about the chem trail. People that they,
they, they have a similar kind of
point of view about chem trails.
They think the science is solid,
but we think the science is
solid on global climate change.
And that perception of what I'm saying,
it's going to be the exactly the same
as my perception of as that of them
the science of what is, you
know, what they're pointing
to. Some of it is so nutty.
And one of the ones that I argued with,
this guy created the documentary was
straight off of your site and we went to
nick site and make, has this, um,
thing on his site where it shows,
um, the study that this gentleman
was quoting and his documentary,
it shows the results of the soil sample.
Well,
the sludge sample that he was saying
was a water sample. And so, um,
while I'm going over this information
with him and he's assuring me of the
veracity of these tests, and I know what
this guy told me that this is water,
but it says on the sample sludge.
And so we test,
we test this stuff and we read the
results of the, and it says, you know,
x amount of aluminum
and x amount of barrels.
It basically has the same composition
as what a lot of dirt has. Like you've,
you scooped up some dirt, you're
going to find a lot of aluminum in it.
It's like a really natural occurring 7%.
It's an amazing amount cause it's like
savvy were eliminating. Wow. Yeah.
It's one of the most common minerals.
So I say to this guy like,
do you understand that
you're saying that your,
your dirt tested positive for being dirt.
That's what this says.
Like that's crazy. But that is the
best piece of evidence at Chem.
Trails are real, you know, so everyone's
saying like the high levels of aluminum,
high levels of Barium, Lou
aluminum is everywhere. Okay.
It's fucking everywhere.
And if you knew that we wouldn't
be having this discussion.
If you knew that aluminum was in
dirt all over the fucking world,
you wouldn't be worried about
people spraying it from the sky.
Why would they do that? It's everywhere.
It's everywhere. And if it was in the sky,
and this is what really got me annoyed,
talked to many people that believe that
those clouds are aluminum and you know
something else like floating in the air.
But if you talk to anybody
who's actually seen aluminum,
it wouldn't look anything
like a fucking cloud.
It wouldn't look like a cloud
and it wouldn't stay in the air,
wouldn't just float there. It's got
weight to it. It's not mist like, well,
you're looking at is actual clouds. It's
not like, like when they sky, right,
that's smoke.
But even that doesn't last
dissipates when they fly over in a,
in a, you know, and you see like a,
a big fat heavy contrail that
that's a fucking cloud man.
That's not aluminum.
That's a cloud.
Yeah. And it's not even really
coming out of the back of the plane.
The plane is just triggering it.
It's making a cloud for and by just
just the spray, not a little condensed.
Haven't documented on my website info.
[inaudible] dot com we've got
high high resolution photographs.
Brian Callan,
they're spraying your children
with Boron and lithium.
What's your stance on tower seven?
Uh, where do you want to know?
Because that's one of the things
that drives me the most crazy.
I just how much it's like, please stop,
you know, uh, do you, do you think,
wait a minute,
it drives you the most crazy that people
talk about it as a conspiracy? Yeah.
Why is it driving me crazy?
Because it's just like people thinking
that it was exploded to eighth.
Do you believe? I think it just caught
fire and the collapse. Yeah. Now I,
the heat that it says it made, there's
some people saying that it was, you know,
there's a huge amount of, uh, different
things that people might bring up.
A nine 11.
And it's one of the big problems with,
with deep on King is that there's just
an endless stream of things that people
will bring it up. They'll say,
hey, what about the hotspots?
What about the free for, what about
the little bits of fire? What about,
what about the squibble explosions on
the side of the building and you can go
through each one of them and you can
address each one individually and explain
what's actually going on.
Let me tell you how I approached it. I
looked at it, the first thing I said,
oh my God, they detonated
that thing for sure. I said,
the way I looked to me like
the thing exploded, um,
or rather a collapsed into its foundation.
I'd never seen a building do that before.
It a hole on the side of it
where it had been hit by the,
uh, the towers that were falling.
And even though there's this
big chunk missing from one side,
it fell uniformly kinked in the mental
and felt like the controlled demolition.
And so I was looking at it,
I was like, you know what,
that looks like a fucking
controlled demolition.
And then I realized that I'm stupid and
I'm not an engineer at all and I don't
know the tolerances of fire
and metal and the metal,
the concrete. And I'm looking at this
and yeah, it did fall free, fall speed.
But maybe that's what fucking
happens when you get this car.
And people were like,
well there's never been a building that
sort of burned to the ground and felt
like that in clubs.
That's true.
But there's also never been a bridge
like that giant bridge in Minnesota that
just collapsed and those
people were driving over it.
Remember that it was a big fucking
tragedy, man. It bridges collapsed.
Sometimes people,
they design shit and then when they
put it together it's sucks, you know?
And sometimes you have these giant fires
that exposes the fact that your design
sucks.
Well genuine.
They have to change building codes
afterwards because of the, the,
the reason the building seven collapse
they think is that what they had these
very long spans of the floor and went in
wasn't secured as well as the other end.
So it pushed one end off and
that fell and that kind of
go pull it up, pull it up Brian, just
let's look, look at it in real time.
Cause it's,
it is incredible how fast it falls.
It literally falls free fall speed.
It's like the whole thing,
kids out uniformly and it
just collapses into its base.
He is very misleading because a lot of
the times people show you this video of
the building collapsing in the show from
afterward the penthouse falls where the
penthouse is falling in
world trade centuries.
It's showing the interior of
the building is collapsing. Hmm.
And when you actually see the
building itself collapsing,
there's pretty much nothing left of
the outside of the outside the inside.
It's either it's either collapse or it's
in the process of collapsing and you've
got this very strong skin outside.
That's the other thing about building
seven the interior set up on this big
screen in a second.
The idea of jet fuel burning so hot that
it melts metal nonsense though cause it
doesn't burn hot enough to melt it.
It Burns hot enough to weaken it.
Let's watch it here. Let's watch
this sucker go down. Ready?
That's like several
seconds into the collapse.
I'm going to tell you something.
If I was Larry Silverstein,
I would sue the fuck out of whoever
built me that shitty building.
God Damn. Because if that isn't
some grand conspiracy, the CIA,
the DEA, they have their documents in
that building along with major banks.
Isn't that a part of the conspiracy side?
But is that true? That is true, right?
Yeah. They had some documents
in there and they lost the sun.
Just stuff them sons of bitches are in
awesome. I shop on a computer. No, no, no,
no backup. They don't do backup.
They write things down on paper.
It was all in that building.
Alluded that shit up.
They blew that shit up to
protect the evidence. Um,
and I'm not saying that Alex is wrong
again cause I am stupid, but uh,
I would be fucking pissed off if I made
that building and it fell apart like
that. God Damn, I be
expected that to happen.
The building was, wants to coat
that was like, they just didn't
know that that type of
thing was going to happen.
The idea that they could have giant
diesel fucking tanks in the basement is
running everything. They had
giant diesel tanks. Yeah.
Like that's part of what started this
massive and inferno destroyed. It didn't,
that's more horse shit now
he had the diesel tanks,
they actually recovered a
whole bunch of that data lines.
So they had diesel tanks.
The whole building's on fire and a
diesel tanks didn't catch on fire.
The whole building wasn't on fire.
It was like several floors in
several sections I've ever.
But like the sections with the diesel,
what?
They were isolated and they didn't burn.
They didn't contribute. Hold on a second.
So you're saying that whole thing
wasn't on fire. If it wasn't on fire,
how the fuck did this happen then? Lots
of it was only two. How many floors?
Major floors. I believe right now I
know there was like two, two floors.
That dad the big collapse a, I can't
remember who they were, but uh huh.
And he was 17 and 18. How many
floors were on fire here? Uh,
well most of the floors are on player.
On the south side.
If you look at the south
side of the building,
the entire thing is engulfed in smoke.
Yeah.
Besides always cooler. Why is that?
Everywhere you go. Everywhere you go.
Back on the south side of Chicago,
I just read Lawrence Wright's Pulitzer
Prize winning book called the um,
there looming tower and he
takes five exhaustive years to,
to study the origins
of nine 11 and this Mo,
this sort of Islamic
fundamentalist movement in half
and started in Saudi Arabia
and moved to the sedan and
move to Afghanistan. I mean
if you really, I always say
read the book.
That's totally different side is on fire.
That book was designed by the government.
It is a DC information campaign.
It's been proven on info wars.com
yeah, look at that. That's like,
I just have to take the Alex Jones point
of view of, I'm sure he has documents.
He's my Frankie. Oh did he
thought smoke? There's one entire,
call them in the middle of the faith.
Feel comfortable with that being enough
to bring that fucking building down.
I'm be honest with you,
but what he's saying is that
it pretty much did a collapse,
like one of the floors fucked like fell
down. I understand the whole concept,
but I don't blast buyer though. I
don't buy it. I think the DEA, the NSA,
they place thermite. That's a lot of
people in the building. I'm Laura.
I'm just being honest. I really, I look
at that and I, the way it collapsed, it's
just like God, it, I think it would
need to be really, really, really,
really fucked up. But the thing is
that the explanation of why collapse,
it's just a bit too complicated,
but why is it too complicated to all
those architects and engineers for nine 11
truth or those guys, all crazy
heads that just kind of the, uh,
the fringe bottom of the
barrel of the architects and
engineers, oh, how dare you,
how dare you discredit them? Ad Hominem
attacks on these fine gentlemen.
She owed us. A whole bunch of them
are very good at what they do,
but they're not generally experts in
structural engineering of large buildings
and their reactions to fire because
when that building was built,
the people who were engineers at that
time thought that it was perfectly safe
and they thought if there was a fire,
it wasn't going to collapse because
they didn't factor in this one thing.
You know, I look at it and it looks like
a controlled demolition to me, but again,
I'm saying it is.
What I'm
saying is,
remember the story I told you about Ted
Nugent shooting the deer and the side
and the Arrow comes out of the top of it.
Weird Shit fucking happened sometimes
and you get some asshole bid.
You a shitty ass building. This
building, man, this building sucks.
A fat one dude and it's got a little
bitty firing it. It just collapses.
Or really a little bitty fired off
to bring it down. A giant building.
Yeah,
or the CIA or had documents.
What about the thermite? Can you
disprove the thermodynamic West? Oh,
you can't disprove,
hey,
stop trying to skirt around my questions
with your new world order. Flim flam
do you disprove thermite while those,
you know, it really built bummed me out.
There was a photo that someone had
sent me, uh, like look at this dude.
This is proof that there had to be some
sort of thermite involve in the cutting
of the steel at the base of the building
fact and this guy turned out to be,
he's a, he's an author of questionable
literature. It's just, no,
I think it's all of this stuff
is fucking cuckoo head shit.
Cause I looked at it and I found
out that no, that's not what it is.
They actually put that stuff on.
They actually cut those things at
the end when they were doing cleanup.
That's from a torch. They sliced
it down with a torch. What was,
well I'm sorry,
what people were sending these,
these emails when these mass
emails showing these cuts
that had been made during
cleanup, when you know, the, the, the,
the towers fell down devastating,
destructive,
huge impact.
They had to clean up all the debris and
they had a cut a lot of it up and the
photos of the, the stuff cut up.
People were sending it around.
It's proof of thermite.
They use thermite look at it sliced at
an angle could not have been possibly
created by the explosion of the building.
That's a fire right there.
That's a big ass fire. Yeah. But
how many floors is that though?
Is that enough to bring down my building?
I'll fucking sue you bitch.
That was my building based on
the north side of the talent.
So you can see these lists.
Embraceable fires cause all the fires
started when light the World Trade Center
to you like oh one I understand
and I understand it for the record,
I just want to let everybody know and
when I say that it looks like a controlled
demolition.
I'm definitely not saying that it is
or not saying it does look like it does
look like.
And I'm not saying that I have any right
to debate the structural merits of this
building. I've, I have no nothing.
I'm completely retarded when it comes
to that and my dad's an architect.
Oh is he?
Yeah.
I mean I guess I could call him up and
ask him some questions about point about
the fact that you have a lot of so called
experts on that truth commission thing
or did that people the truth,
there's a bottom of the barrel
arbitrary or or their expertise isn't,
isn't huge structures and how they would,
how they respond to fire and
and impact. I mean, yeah,
that's a specific shitty contractors who
fuck you over and make you a building
that when you let a couple of floors on
fire just fucking falls apart. Couple of,
a couple of, I did see huge planes. I was
into those buildings. No other one. That's
tower seven. I know. Silly Bitch.
Yeah. That's the big argument.
Tower stuff is only building,
never felt like it's the work right here.
There I used to work right if a couple
of blocks away. It's really sad.
There's a lot of people that live in that
area too that stayed after the impact
and they were inhaling chemicals,
toxic chemicals on a daily basis.
Like Donna Summers, man. Donna
Summers died of lung cancer. Yes.
And she lived in that area. Wow. Yeah,
she lived right near the, um, the,
the towers and she died of lung cancer.
She didn't even smoke. Yeah. It happened.
It happened to a lot of people.
It's not a small thing.
I mean that the impact
of that thing is firemen,
cops to turn them to workers,
all first, first responders.
A lot of those guys got really,
really, really sick. Yeah.
That's something that doesn't get taken
into consideration when you talk about
the death toll of those things.
But that is a really worthy thing to think
about as opposed to the idea that the
government engineered it and
there was this conspiracy,
these guys didn't even know how to fly.
And some of the high that hit the
hitchhikers hijackers are still alive.
They're in Saudi Arabia. Like,
man, I don't know. I don't know.
I Dunno. What has happened
has been, I mean, like I said,
there's been so much good
journalism. I mean, Oh,
good investigative and
exhaustive journalism that, that,
that will tell you the story.
So many different stories though.
That's part of the problem is complicated,
but people don't have the time cause
these complicated stories. Here's what I,
here's one point that I bring up. Whenever
people talk about conspiracy theories,
I say, do you believe in nine 11?
And when they say they do, and I say,
well then you believe in conspiracy
theories because people conspired.
They pulled that off and they did it and
it was a real conspiracy and that shit
is real and it does happen.
Absolutely.
Just like a lot of other conspiracies
that happened throughout time that were
absolutely proven to be real events.
There's a lot of them.
There's not just one or two.
They, they, they, you know,
from all the evidence that I've
read and that seems credible,
that a group of dedicated fanatics under
the banner of fundamentalist Islam got
together, got financed and pulled
off this pretty amazing feat,
which was very different.
See, I wouldn't say that I believe
that entirely. Um, without,
without any pause because I don't
know anything about flying a plane.
Okay.
I don't know anything about being able
to do the maneuvers that those people
have done,
but I've seen these specials where they
break down whether or not a plane would
actually be able to hit the Pentagon
like it did and take the path that it did
and then the people can't reproduce
that in the simulator and that they have
been able to control planes by
the use of a drone technology.
They've been able to do that
since the 1960s in fact,
that was part of the northwest document.
Part of the northwest document was
exploding a fake a plane and pretending it
was filled with people.
But we're going to take a drone and fly
it up and blow it up. So this
was a commercial airline? Yeah,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still a plane and we know
that you can control the plane.
We could control it.
Jet With drone technology as far back as
the 1960s so whether or not that was a
part of what got me,
maybe these guys took over the,
they had to take over the cockpit
to allow that to take place. Like,
we don't know they're dead, but the,
the maneuvers that those jets did,
it could have easily been something like
someone had hijacked and hacked into
the system and figured out how to turn
that diegetic to a drone. Not Difficult.
I talked a lot of pilots. I'm the one
that went into the Pentagon. Yeah. Really.
We'll talk about it being this light, you
know, death spiral that they had to do.
But if you look at it on the map,
it's really just a very slow
descending three 60 loop.
But it at an incredible speed,
right by a guy who wasn't experienced
pilot and had no experience flying those
kinds of jets.
The speed that the planes fly out,
he didn't actually make any difference
to the maneuvering cause it's, it's all,
it's all relative razor
outcomes, razor two things. One,
you're certainly right. Um,
the more likely scenario is that they
pulled off these incredible and Hoover's.
He's incredible banks
into the more likely,
well for these people that didn't
know how to fly. For a guy like me,
it's what I did that they went to school
for it, they went to school. And we all,
we have, we have, we have FBI, uh, one
of the biggest things you have to be,
I never shared that information with
the CIA for a whole bunch of reasons,
mainly because they in some ways
weren't even allowed to, uh,
because there's always been
a firewall between FBI,
between spying on domestic and,
and,
and an end and an international
and there's actually laws involved.
But one of the things that we know for
sure is that these people in the CIA knew
that. I mean the FBI knew this
and we have documents about this.
We knew these people were studying.
We were at,
we're at flight simulation schools,
we know that.
So they have the commercial licenses.
The guy flew into the Pentagon has a
committal listen, very hard to get right.
And my point thing, you just
get from like, you know,
flying Microsoft flight simulator for a
few hours or something that you have to
do hours and hours and hours of practice.
I totally, I totally understand. And uh,
like I said,
most likely that's what happened.
But then I also leave open the possibility
that they had an insurance policy and
they didn't allow these guys to decide
whether or not they wanted to fly right
into a fucking building and smash into it.
I don't know.
That's not what comes razor.
Oh No, you're, no it's not.
I said that was the first part.
The first I agree with you.
That's what I'm saying. I don't have
a, I don't have a dog in this race.
What I'm saying is that I do know that
there was some sort of technology that
allowed them to use drone technology to
control jets as recent as far back as
1960s not saying that
that's what happened,
but saying that what you saw
could be replicated with drones.
I think the technology is there.
Any amateur pilot could probably
have pulled off what they were doing.
It really wasn't that hard.
It's not that hard.
Certainly to fly into the buildings wasn't
that hard and my father and my father
was a pilot for 20 years and he said,
that's very easy.
It's steering a plane is pretty much
easier though. It's during a call.
You just really easy to,
well,
why don't they release the videos for
the Pentagon being hit by the players?
A question. Why is that? By the way,
why don't we have video of those
planes flying into the Pentagon?
We do have that one from
the uh, the parking garage
where you can stay for a few,
a few frames. There's a, yeah, it comes
in, it looks more like a missile to me.
Ms. West, I would just, uh,
I don't see any reason why
they would be like, you know,
that many video cameras pointing
at that parking lot of this.
Well that's not the case though.
There are, there are videos.
There's certainly our videos or video
cameras and video cameras were there.
Their videos were taken.
Right.
It was like they had shown that there
had been more than one video of this.
This was the only one that they apparently
pointing within inside sort of where
we're at,
cameras,
cameras pointing out looking for plaintiff
is coming in. I thought there was
more than one. I thought that,
I'm pretty sure as it got to say this,
yeah.
I have something like something like that,
like a gas station or something nearby
where they had a video of it and they
gave it to the FBI and
the FBI just took it.
But you know the other thing is like
why, why put it out there? I mean if you,
if you were the FBI,
let's say, or the see it,
where the fuck is in charge with this,
right?
You're going door to door and finding
out who's good security cam videos.
Would you want those videos
to go on the Internet?
We've already got these giant towers,
it fells or video or this video.
Would you just sweep the thing up
that shows the hit of the Pentagon?
Cause you know how many times they're
going to show that they're gonna hit show
the main point or building getting
hit by a jet. Oh La, la La.
All their videos is going to start with
that. The jet hitting the Pentagon.
We've coming back for you. Boom.
You know, that's an iconic building.
And like if you did have a video of it
blowing up, I guess they didn't have it.
I supposedly, it didn't record anything.
Yeah, that's what I would say too.
It's kind of,
I mean my day or released it.
I was always surprised that they never
really brought up bin Laden's body back.
I know they didn't want to have
a shrine for people to come to,
so they don't buy that. I don't buy that
one. I don't buy the been loved one.
I think that dude had been dead for
a long time. I think they probably,
Jackson guy will look like him and said,
let's just take that frozen
bid lawn sickle out and toss it in
the other. She had been on sick say,
we got this bitch. Obama was like, listen,
I'm going to, I'm going to work with you.
You're going to work with me.
You're going to get me in the office.
I'm going to look like a
hero. This is what I need. I
need that bin. Ladin sickle,
they had that break glass in case of
publicity. They had that with a bin.
Ladin sickle.
Just sit in there.
Wait for a moment. I met a guy who was
on the raid. I met a seal team six.
Yeah, I bet he'd say, I told you this
while he's fucking you in the ass.
And then I'm gonna tell you something.
I kicked that door open.
I'm going to come grab my
boss, man. I killed him.
I feel in the story. Turns out your
boy wasn't even a seal ticks mailer.
It's just so crazy.
Gay Guy Looks so fuck actors just like
still hold after is down to my store.
I took it up the ass for my country.
I did it for Pat Tillman.
He needs to know the truth.
Ah. So that's the big one
that people will bring up.
Back to the conspiracy
theory is the tower setup.
Yeah. I like, I like to bring
that up because people like,
did you know the three buildings fell on
nine 11 and they make out like this big
thing that's been covered up. It's
covered up. It's totally wrong.
It's not even on the Internet.
Oh wait,
I think it's best if you actually talking
with the nine 11 truth or I want to go
straight to building seven and talk about
that. Oh, go right from the get go. Yeah.
Cause that's the thing that they think
is the real biggest bit of evidence.
Well it certainly looks like a
controlled demolition. Like you'd met.
I can't ever see headlines
of conspiracy theory.
Midwest admits nine 11 it looks like
a controlled demolition. That is it.
I mean they could use that
quote. That is what, that is a quote.
It does look like controlling the militia
Dutch, a demolition expert and they're
saying, oh yeah, that looks
like a controlled demolition.
Then he goes into like
how they might've done it,
but the thing they don't show is that
like 10 minutes earlier he's looking at
the towers falling and said,
oh there's no way that could have been a
controlled demolition. Oh really? Yeah.
Really good guy. Same interview.
Oh, and they didn't do shit.
That's very Michael Morton. Yeah.
You can't do that right now.
You've got to show both sides and you're
just selling entertainment. You know,
I don't mind that. But you gotta
let me know. You know, like have a,
like a disclaimer. I say, listen,
there's some arguments against this,
but fuck them. It's not,
they're moving. Right.
That's then don't call it a documentary
then it's a movie, not a documentary.
I would do that and then would have,
I would play the whole movie and then I
would use the trailer and the truck at
the end, the trailers,
all me getting owned.
I get tricked you.
I did.
I gave a movie where I pretend that I had
a point when I uncovered some secrets,
but it really,
I left out all the arguments against my
stupid theories and at the end of it,
I just got owned and I didn't
play that until the very end.
I'd watch it. Um, do people
get mad at you? Yeah.
People think that you're a government
agent. Yeah. I've, I've had, uh,
more than one person tell me to look
out Midwest of government agent.
Are you a government agent?
Maybe I look like I could see that.
She can't say that because now that's
first of all, why didn't he just say no?
Ask me. Brian Count asked me Joe
Rogan and you a government agent.
No de mic. Yes, I am. No, I'm not.
But I think you're so
fucking contradictory.
I believe you less and less every morning.
I think he's actually like a useful or
useful exercise for people to assume that
I am a government agent.
Well that makes what?
What have I said that's wrong.
That's cool.
We are both actually in
the Illuminati by the way.
You're in the and iTunes and she
didn't tell me, why won't you tell me,
what did they give you? Oh cool. Vodka.
Is there a conspiracy theory or is
there something for both of you?
Cause I know you've been
doing this show now,
is there something that kind of that you
had trouble explaining where you just
kind of went, well that is
pretty amazing. You know,
nothing that springs to mind but
that there are like, you know,
real conspiracies out of that.
That's his point is what I like
about Mick is that he is skeptical,
but he also is realistic about
what has and hasn't taken place.
It's not like you're trying to
debunk everything that could,
that's a conspiracy and that becomes
a problem because of that word.
That word conspiracy is a weird word.
Like,
even though there are
people can inspire to
do things, you know, even though you know,
did Oswaldo kill JFK?
I don't know.
I don't know if Oswald killed JFK,
but I know that there was someone who
conspired to kill JFK and got away with
it. I know there was a lot of,
a lot of things that happened.
There's a lot of people involved.
You know, whether it was the whoever,
the Cubans or whoever hired Oswald or
whether it was other people that were in
the grassy knoll,
which is still a distinct possibility,
still a distinct possibility. There's
just not enough evidence. And the,
the fuckery involved in the JFK
assassination, is it an all time high?
Just the fact that they concluded that
a third bullet or that this bullet had,
they had,
they had found a chipped
kerbstone underneath the
overpass and because of that
they had to attribute all these
different wounds to one bullet.
That's where the magic
bullet theory came from.
A much more realistic possibilities
that he was hit by more than one bullet.
Sure. Much more real
estate. Not only that,
much more realistic to think that they
really did hire this mob guy to fucking
sneak pass all these cops and shoot Oswald
before he could talk, which they did.
They sound like this mob guy was
this guy who is like, you know,
I'm fucking pro America and this fucking
cock suckers dot going to kill my
president, and he ran up on
them and with the cops there,
no one is life is on the line, please. I
think that guy got talked into it. They,
oh, he owed money. He owed something.
When you look at the Jack Ruby story,
that's a guy who was a crook whose whole
life involved in organized crime his
whole life.
Complete degenerate scum bag club owner
deep in bed with the mom probably had a
gambling problem, please.
There's a constant,
there's a conspiracy there.
There's no doubt about it.
The magic bullet thing though,
I think that's one of the things that
has become accepted in the conspiracy
culture as being just,
it's an article of faith that it was
impossible for the magic bullet to,
it happened.
It's also an article of faith that it
was possible when you consider the fact
that it showed up on the
Gurney on Connolly's Gurney
in the hospital. Oh look,
they found the bullet in almost
pristine condition. Well,
we're totally trustworthy type people,
so by it please.
But the magic bullet has been
replicated a couple of times with,
I haven't seen that
really? Where's that? Yeah.
I think it was a discovery channel
thing or, oh, no, no, no, no, no.
They didn't replicate it.
I know what you're talking about.
They only replicated it when it
didn't hit bone. They did replicated,
but when it hit bone, every time they hit
bone, it became contorted in the store.
They did it through Gel.
They did it through a bunch of different
things that mimic human tissue.
It's very difficult to
exactly what happened,
but they got something that was close
enough that it seemed close. Ooh,
I disagree. I disagree on that one because
I've seen that special. I know exactly.
I know. The Guy who think and know the
guy who was involved in that. Was it?
There wasn't a Jesse Ventura when he was
it, was it a mythbusters one? Yes. Todd,
the guy who produced my show, uh,
also, uh, did some work on mythbusters.
I have to ask him what, what the exact
specifics works. I'm pretty sure.
Yeah. No, I mean, now I'm thinking
it's not even a mythbusters one,
but do they had a jelly thing with like
bone in it and when it hit the bone and
would get fucked up more fucked
up than that bullet. I mean,
the bull was in pretty amazing shape.
It's even if it did,
let's say that obviously I wasn't there.
I don't know whether or not the magic
bullet really took the trajectory that
it's being attributed to, but
let's say if it did, it's amazing.
It's amazing that the
bullet came out like that.
It doesn't mean that it's not possible,
but it's amazing.
It's amazing that it went through
two people caused all that damage,
left fragments inside their bodies that
they had to remove. Pretty incredible.
When you look at what it looks like,
so is it impossible? Of course.
I would never say that.
I don't know.
I didn't look the biggest thing as Jack
Ruby actually running a shooting. I,
there's no reason that that was,
that was very interesting to me.
It's fascinating. Fascinating
Oswald. So obviously he,
they wanted Oswald quiet jack when we
didn't do that because he felt bad for
Jackie.
There's more than enough evidence to
indicate that there was more than one
person involved. It wasn't just just
him, just by the paper trail. I mean,
the fact that the guy, the guy,
he'd been to Cuba, Soviet Union,
I mean he had a Russian wife and
brought her back with them. I mean,
this guy was like, uh, he was
involved in some really weird shit.
And just that alone,
like if,
if Oswald was the shooter
and it was just Oswald man,
there had to be a lot of
other people involved in this.
This is not something that he decided
to do on his own. One day I seen that.
I couldn't believe how steep
that trajectory was, but
he shot right down on it,
which I thought he was shot.
He didn't do it.
What do you think fucking shot that
guy for the grassy knoll overall?
Do you think he did it?
I would probably like, yeah. Or
on the side of him doing it. Uh,
I think there's lots of
unanswered questions. And again,
this is like hundreds and hundreds of
books being written and I'll promote
perspectives on it.
I don't think it's a question
we're ever really going to answer.
And it's a really hard one to debunk
because you can't do it satisfactorily.
Even things like the magic bullet,
it's really,
really hard to actually prove
that that would have happened.
You can prove that something like that
might have happened, but you know,
it's maybe kind of unlikely and it was
just a lucky shot and this thing's like a,
the back to the left thing, whether he
hit his head, goes back to the left. Uh,
and it's, you know, I, I've
had long debates about that
on, on the forum and, uh, uh,
it's just a very hard thing to convince
people that that might have been like,
you know, the bullet hitting from behind
and he's head goes back. Uh, because like,
you know,
bullets don't actually impart that much
velocity into people's heads when they
get shot in the head. But
people, you know, they have this,
these articles of faith that because
he's had went back into the left,
then he must've been shot from the front.
So that must have been another gun man.
Well, you know what, um,
I actually kind of disagree that it
goes back into the left. Initially.
I think the initial spray
actually comes forward,
which is virtually impossible if you're
getting shot from the front. And uh,
I think there is something that
other people need to consider.
I think he was shot
from all over the place.
I think the whole and the trake that
they made a tray, Cole and his neck,
I think that has an impact wound.
I think it's been pretty,
it's been pretty well argued based.
The difference between the autopsy report
in I'm in Dallas and then the autopsy
report and Bethesda,
Maryland that they were looking
at two totally different things.
They were describing wounds in a
different way and there's been,
it's been widely reported that they had
generals standing over the hospital bed
directing doctors on how
to report this stuff.
If that's true and if there really were
military people that are allowed inside
the operating room and the president's
body was brought in and they really did
define where the wounds came from,
who knows what the motive would have
been in 1963 and a mad scramble when the
president's been myrtle. Who knows
how much shitty thinking is involved.
How much of is a personality conflict
between a general and a doctor doesn't
want him in the room. Who knows what
the fuck is going on? Who knows,
but if I was going to shoot the president,
I wouldn't kind of one guy to pull it off.
Why would you do that?
If you can get one Lee
Harvey Oswald Asshole,
you can get five more dudes sitting to
grassy knoll and fucking peck this guy
off as he's driving towards you, you're
not going to just shoot, you're not gonna.
If there's a grand conspiracy to kill the
president, which most likely there was.
I just don't see Oswald being like,
I'm going to do this on my own.
I don't need any help. No
assassin's. I've always in.
A lot of times it's been people who were
on the fringe of some kind of movement
or Gee, I think, sure. You know,
and, but they were generally
and essentially loners.
I think for the most part, you know, guys
who had always had trouble fitting in,
you know,
and we're trying to look to be significant
and we're loosely attached to several
different organizations
are at one organization,
whether it was at and
usually a general way.
How many of them have there been that
you can make such a rash generalization?
I'm thinking about boots.
Something about the Guy John
Tried to kill the guy who shot,
who shot the archduke Ferdinand and
his wife at the beginning of world war.
That sort of sparked world war one. I'm
thinking about the guy who assassinated,
uh, Lincoln. The, these guys were,
were one was a Serbian terror.
Uh, how do we know that all
those weren't conspiracies to,
and then someone was behind
the scenes manipulating, well,
they're not manipulating
Bryan county back then.
You're part of a group that has a stated
mission and goal, which is what a,
I can't remember the guy's
name who killed, but look
at Sirhan Sirhan who shot,
uh, you know, Bobby Kennedy, that
guy tried to assassinate the pope.
These people are generally,
you know, loners.
We did fear factor in that kitchen
is, yeah. Yeah. It's creepy.
Walked right through that bitch.
So like how is this not like a
part of the history that's in la?
It's not even there anymore.
I'm pretty sure they tore it down.
It was like a landmark. It was a
hotel and they were using it for, um,
for filming there.
Would people do like the horror
movies there and shit got shot there.
Actually you shot film there.
I mean Christ,
Brian [inaudible] guys know that yes,
Jesus Christ aren't just talking about
assassins and basically named yourself
talking about what is our owner.
You are so embarrassed how
you go against the grain.
You make impulsive decisions and shooting
the president. Ariane, I'm a contrarian.
I think at JFK that was one of those
conspiracy theories that you can never
really deep on. I love that
you're willing to admit that it's,
it's like you know everything's so far
in the past the evidence has been gone
over with a fine tooth comb and there's
still all these like case closed.
I hate those guys on both sides.
You get people who will say it's
definitive one way or the other but then
there's just so much unknown about it
that you never going to be able to close
it.
But there are,
there are conservation theories that
you can prove that aren't going on.
Like the chem trail thing.
And there are aspects of the,
the broader theories like,
like JFK and nine 11 that you can address.
You can address individual
points of evidence,
but I don't think you're ever really
going to be able to debunk nine 11.
It's just, it's going to go on
forever. Basically, people look at,
there's always going to be some people
who are going to think that there was an
inside job.
Hitler burned the rash tag.
Nero burned Rome. Of course,
you know, all these things.
You're a student of history being an
disinformation agent from another country.
It probably taught you about America and
our history of this great land for you.
Came over here. You
sound like man cow. No,
he's more Chicago. I did his, did
his, uh, cause he still right.
Well he's sort of like, he's paying,
putting on an act. He puts on an activity.
Like we had an argument, fake
argument about Carlos Man. See Ya.
He was wearing his sunglasses at
seven in the morning. I was like,
this isn't gonna go well. How
he was running back, I dunno,
I wear sunglasses in studio
are problematic. Oh my God.
He was acting like a rock star.
Like he was doing something like writing,
like flying a spaceship. I was
like, Bro, relax. You're just,
you're doing a radio show. I'm feeling
good about this. Look. Oh, there it is.
Ladies and gentlemen, put it on the back
of the famous man. This is how you know,
this is how you know you're slipping
when you take pictures like this. Sorry,
Anthony Bourdain.
I love you.
That's when you know you're
slipping Anthony Bourdain's
picture the CNN pictures
like this. I love that guy. I know
he gets away with it. Oh he does?
He gets a free pass on everything he
does. He's my boyfriend. He's awesome.
I love that guy. Yeah, you do. You're
actually, you've got a man crush on board.
Dang.
He's a great guy.
He's one of the few people that I was
giddy about getting to eat dinner with.
I've had dinner with them
and drinks and got laid up,
got lit up in Montreal together.
Oh, he's beautiful person, man.
We talked to like fucking three o'clock
in the morning till they kicked us out
of the bar. No so much. He's
just a great guy. He's a great,
interesting guy that sees the world and
didn't become famous till he was older
in life.
So He's very appreciative of it and
very balanced and he's all about like
putting in the work is all about like
just living the life and just putting a
guy we shot. We did meet either with, it
was one of his camera. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was talking about it.
Boy,
if you want to have a fucking cushy Gig
as a cameraman, man, what a cool gig.
Rather Bordain and then meat eater.
Two totally different things.
One of them you're standing for
stars, hotels, the other one,
you're in a fucking bag of cloth.
It's 16,000 degrees below zero and you're
trying to kill a buffalo with a spear.
This show meat eaters. One of my, I,
I'd have to say it's my favorite show.
So show I look forward to the most,
especially after a Brian and I,
we went hunting on it with this guy.
He goes hunting because it's like,
does fair chase hunts goes
out in the middle of like,
you know, it goes to Alaska.
This week was Alaska was hunting bears
that were searching for blueberries in
the high altitude. Did you, did you
get, um, did you get your gear yet? Yes,
I haven't. I haven't. I've been slacking.
Shit, bitch. Ryan Kennedy, Carolyn again.
Ryan, Kelly, man. I got to
come Kai and I got to call you.
She sent me probably email them. Don't use
the podcast. You Fuck? I was, what other,
um, what other, um, conspiracies are
like big ones that you get asked to,
to debunk all the time. Uh, well, you
know, people bring up things like Ufo.
What about Elvis? Yeah.
Uh, oh, this is bullshit.
You alive and just decided enough was
enough. Man. Didn't want the life.
That's the Michael Hastings thing.
Ah, the Michael Hastings thing.
And this is where you're going to
show what a, what a government shill.
You really are.
You going to tell me the Michael
Hastings car wasn't rigged to explode and
flying to that tree at
a hundred miles an hour.
It looks exactly like he was just driving
like a crazy guy and he hit the tree.
I hit a bump in the,
maybe the government use their mind
control h everyone's looking for a drone.
It's not a drone.
They don't turn your car into a drone
that technology's not available yet,
but they can Manchurian candidate you,
they can get inside your mind and
convince you that for the greater good of
mankind and the cause that you're
involved in driving to a fucking tree.
They released show. I found the photos
when actually it would be we're filled.
I was went to the set
with you on fear factor.
The day that we went to that hotel
and I found the photos that I took. Oh
Wow. Where's torn down? Old
School old school stuff.
So he was a shot in that kitchen.
Yeah. Wow. That's creepy shit.
Yeah.
And the 17 different gunshots
rang out in three seconds.
You tell me how that's possible with one
shooter. Midwest. Go ahead. Your turn. Um,
I dunno sir. Hands. Her hand was
a Buddhist who killed a biggie.
He ate flowers
or Tupac.
Do you even follow those kinds of
things are not there. You don't debunk.
Begin to pop because they're black. Is
that what you're saying? So you're racist.
Wait a minute. You go all the way to
back my shaft. K before your time.
JFK is not before your time,
but big. He is. How dare you.
You fucked it. People don't
bring a biggie. You are
hanging out with white people.
You're hanging out with
white people in Venice.
It's big with English accents
and go to art galleries.
You don't know what the
fuck you're talking about.
There is the generally wine.
Well that's one of the things you said
on a show. That's what he, what do you,
what do you get? What do you find
when you look at for the Sasquatch?
I'll tell you, we don't find black
people. No black people. There's not one.
We were,
me and Dunkin formed a group while we
were out squash and called unfuckable
white dudes and it was me and him
and those two dudes. And we were uh,
we were out there steady squash and that
was our band. He unfuckable white dudes.
What about,
what about Ufo?
Because that's actually another thing
he can't really deep on because a lot of
them are just identify flying objects
though that lights in the sky and he'd
done it. What to do we have any pictures?
Do we have any pictures that are really,
really convincing? All of them. Oh, we
don't pull shit. Listen, this guy's,
it's a shill. He's a shell. The
information, look at that drawing. Okay,
look at this statue that I have.
That's a real alien. Tell me.
If you look at that in your heart
and your soul, you know that,
that to be really alien. I think
there might be, it's an archetype.
There's almost let less Ufo pitchers
coming out now than they were back in the
late fifties and people are
scared to speak their mind
because of ridicule. Okay.
Because people like Kim,
what they've done is they've,
they've made it seem like you're a silly
person. Yeah. If you send in your photos,
you're turning out mic while I'm, I'm
assuming this was show need some balance.
You're trying to create controversy and
conflict. Basically what I'm telling you,
Bryan, calendars and aliens
are real. Roswell happened.
I am stopped trying to deny it.
I just need some proof. Sir.
There's no proof necessary. I know. You
need to know is that the, the sky is huge.
That's true way.
That is something I never really think
about it just how vast the university is.
It's
someone's high.
I never really think about
how big the universe is
talking about this. Why does it,
why do they always look like that?
I do you know the story that comes from
the Fifties Duncan Trussell told me this
story. He said that when
you are being born, okay.
People assume that when you're being born
you have no memory of uh, your, your,
your childhood.
But why would we assume that just because
you don't have a context to put that
memory into just because the one of
the most traumatic moments of doubt,
young brains, life we'll be
getting yanked out of its warm,
incredible environment of love with
it's mommy and then taking it into some
bright clinical place where a man is
hovering over you with complete control.
You can't move your body.
You're being lifted up and carry
to this tray and dropped down.
You're looking down at this guy who's
got this white mask on these black eyes
and the archetype of this man's face when
your eyeballs have never even adjusted
to being able to see reality.
I mean, you're not looking,
you're not popping out of a fucking of
vagina filled with liquids and blood and
then seeing crystal clear,
right.
My eyes are blurry when I get
out of the fucking shower, right?
When you get out of the pool,
if you've been swimming a public pool,
your eyes turn rent.
Do you imagine what your eyes must look
like being in gallons of vagina fluid
for nine months? Blind close, but
they open up there in the water.
There's a lot of shit going on.
You don't know.
You don't know if they're open to there.
I don't know.
Megan shutout blood and then the pressure
of that pussy squeezing on your head.
All of that's going to fuck up your
vision. It's supposed to be, if it's,
it's a pussy.
If you're going to have sex with it,
and if you didn't have sex with it,
she wouldn't have a baby.
You're coming out of it. It's a vagina.
Once you have sex with it, it's a to,
it's not bad that it's supposed to.
It's supposed to.
It's not bad if it's your daughter,
it's a vagina,
and if it's your wife even have to
just set up baby. It's opposing.
The baby came out of the pussy,
the baby staring at this alien,
and that that image is somehow shocked.
The image,
the memory of the clinical experience,
and it really does kind
of make sense that these
ideas that people have of this
hypnotic regression bringing up this,
this alien abduction experiences that
completely of squashed well, what is,
what would be a traumatic moment
that you really did squash?
How about your birth, your fucking
birth, getting shot in for the light.
It's impossible light that
you never could have imagined.
Then nine months you've been alive and
the x amount of time you've actually been
thinking about things a lot more aliens
wearing masks. If a, that was good.
I don't think there's a real image.
I think that's why the owl,
the eyes are dark and the rest of
the features are sort of nonexistent.
Or maybe it's just somebody who to the
flood, but that's just an artist's image.
The actual, what the reoccurring
inch is actually the eyes,
the,
the variation in the face and other people
describe it being abducted by aliens.
They all described kind of a similar,
it's a very similar archetype
and the question is, is,
is that archetype because of
culture? Because like, you know,
like people see big foot,
right.
The idea is that that's what they're
looking for us because that's what
everybody's told them to go look for like
flying saucers. That's one where the,
uh, the guy who first
reported flying saucers was a
fighter pilot and he reported
these things skipping across the sky and
said that there were like saucers on a
lake,
like someone skipping a saucer and that,
but that he didn't mean even
saucer shaped. They were
actually a boomerang shape.
That what he was saying that he saw.
It sounds like he fell that everybody
after that started seeing saucers,
they started seeing actual discs.
Why?
Because that had been putting image
that had been put in their hands.
I was going to say, that's
interesting. You know,
he may have been totally sleep deprived
and completely hallucinating or on meth
or whatever. They were given pilots, man,
they were giving pilots
meth for a long time.
We went over on the show recently how
much math was involved in the kamikaze
pilots, how much math was involved in
the Nazis and I'm awake and it was,
people didn't even know
it was bad for you then.
Like there's people that
doctors are prescribing math at.
Doctors were taking a methamphetamine
in medical school. Yes.
So it's not outside the
realm of possibility.
This guy really did see
disks flying through the sky.
It's also not outside the realm
of ability. Realm of possibility.
This guy was tripping his fucking balls
off on some government shit. No sleep.
The earliest version
of pro vigil they had,
they're pumping into this fucking
guy or pro vigil really works.
It is explained to me. Do you
know it's not a, it's not a,
it's not a central nervous
stimulant. Actually. It's
something else. It keeps it,
I can't explain it because like as I am
not an architect, I'm also not a doctor.
I would give you a fucked up
explanation of what it is. But, um,
there's some people that swear by it,
some Weirdos, you know, I had a doctor to,
to who was at sleep specialist.
I sat next to him by coincidence
at dinner and he said it to,
he was explaining how it worked,
but he said it's not a stimulant away.
Caffeine would be a stimulant.
It just keeps you awake for 14 hours
and you can function highly on.
What's really interesting
is it was first created as a
performance enhancing drug,
mental performance enhancing drug.
But they couldn't market it that way
because the government's like, no,
you can't have a drug that just
makes your brain work better.
Like you have to have a reason, you have
to be an ailment that you're treating.
And so they said, okay,
narcolepsy. Oh Wow.
And so then they started prescribing it
for narcolepsy or off brand or how would
they say, what does it off, off
label, off label, off label use. So,
so we'll provigil kind of center
your mind. Well I'll tell him,
let Brian describe it cause I gave one
to Brian was about to fucking fall asleep
once he had two hours sleep. And he was
driving to San Diego. He's like, dude,
I don't know how I'm going to do
it. I go take this. And I don't, I,
I'm very judicious with them.
I only take them when I need,
when I haven't had sleep,
when I need energy for a long
sustained period of time.
Like occasionally,
if I'm feeling entitled,
take a half a one before a UFC and it
doesn't give you any speediness to it.
It's not like drinking red bull. It's
not like you're anything, it just,
it gives you like less dips in
your energy. It just turns you on.
Like it's just like, that's not even
a like tiredness or, or just like,
like where I just need to lay down for a
bid or just like, eh, but it's all gone.
As Tim Ferriss said, he doesn't believe
in a biological free lunch and it's, it's,
it seems to have like a really positive
benefit, which also makes me think like,
well, okay, what, is there anything
bad going on here because of this?
Like just seems like seems like a
pretty abusive, well, yeah, absolutely.
That's very important.
But also I'm,
I don't take it very often and only
take a half of one. I never go all in.
I don't need it. I just think like a
little bit, just a little bit as good.
I don't want to feel like Ooh, like
an effect. But if you take a full one,
you'll feel like a blue, like a
little bit of a rush. And I know, um,
that it's a,
a big rumor among silica,
silicon valley startups that like all
these guys who just provigils out of their
mind and they have massive energy to
complete projects that work at 16 hours a
day and they're all just fucking pop
and provigil and there's no bodies,
you know,
and people are really worried about so
much so that Tim Ferriss kept it from his
book. I go, why'd you
leave it on your book goes,
I don't want people just chewing
on it like candy. I was like, wow,
it's so effective that you were worried
about your own responsibility or
personal responsibility for intro
introducing it to people. Tim Ferriss,
a good guy. Yeah. Well,
I've heard of the same with the
disastrous side effects for Adderall.
And I have actually seen people that
I've been friends with have had problems
with Adderall. Adderall
is no joke. I was awful.
I mean if you split it down to like
little teeny pieces, it might be okay.
But like you take one Adderall pill,
you feel like you're on crack cocaine.
Like I feel like I get drips,
like I'm having flashback from doing
coke back cause it's that same feeling
tuning into that feeling. Wow. Yeah.
That Adderall thing though is a real issue
with folks. Okay, here's a conspiracy.
I'm with that.
What do you think about,
do you think that the government
conspires with pharmaceutical companies to
prescribe certain amounts of drugs
so they can profit off of it?
I think that is certainly like a big
problem with leather regulation of drugs
like this, this big revolving door
of people in government and the
regulatory agencies who basically worked
in industry and then they go work in
the government and then there's the same
people passing laws and regulations, uh,
forward.
See,
see what the financial industry,
that's the real conspiracy
or the EPA and Monsanto.
Did you ever see the, um,
um, there's a show on,
I want to say it's current,
but no, it's not. It's um, uh,
vanguard, the oxycontin express.
Have you ever seen that?
Uh, that the special, it's,
it's available online.
You could see it online and uh,
we've had the folks in that created it, I
forget what network they were on. Sorry.
Current was it current? Yeah. Um,
and they showed the oxycontin problem in
Florida and how easy it is to get pills
and how crazy it is.
They,
they didn't have a database where you can
go from one doctor to another and just
keep getting prescriptions.
They have these pain management
centers set up everywhere where you go.
Literally, they go, oh, my back hurts,
Dr. Write some shit down
in the same building.
They have a pharmacy that only sells pain
pills and these people just cranked to
the gills on Oxycontin's
all day. Well, there's no,
there's no question that
I think corporations will
sometimes if they want to get
something passed,
I mean the food industry will stack the
deck with its scientists that they put
on their payroll to suggest, for example,
that the foods that they're producing,
which are simple sugars and you know,
whether it's craft or something
and they want to sell soda,
they want to sell candy bars in school,
well they'll stack the deck and have
signed to say 25% of your diet as a child
can be simple sugars. We've, we don't
find anything unhealthy about that.
They've been very active about that.
If you read the China study,
t Colin Campbell, who's a scientist,
I mean he's a Vegan and stuff.
I don't agree with that. But like I
said, yeah, but he's, he's incredible.
Is incredible scientist who,
who would have the value of that book for
me was just Wah list reading about how
they stack the deck,
how they're very influential on the
kinds of scientists that set standards.
This is like a,
it's kind of like a real conspiracy, but
it doesn't have to be like, you know,
a bunch of guys in a smoky room
like deciding to do these things.
It's just kind of a bunch of increments.
The,
they push things in one
direction or the other
and it's based on, you know, you can
look at it, the influence very clearly.
And it's like, where's the money
coming from? It's just Monday.
I called you after I read the book and
I remember I just had to talk somebody.
I go,
I remember I called and I said,
I don't know how people
can make a living this way.
I can never pay my
mortgage behaving that way.
When you were talking to me about the,
you called me up and we were telling
me about the richest county, uh, the,
the county in Virginia. It's all
lobbyists. It's all lobbyists and lawyers.
I mean that the Washington has become an
economy of influence. So crazy. I mean,
by the way, I'm sorry to use
that expression, but that's
my trademark. Uh, don't,
don't, don't, don't trademark.
No trouble. But, but, but the,
when you work on Capitol Hill now and
you're a congressman and you're making 140
grand a year or whatever it is,
it is the,
that is the farm league for k street.
All the lobbying firms
are where you go now.
You use your influence after being
in government for six or eight years.
You now move to a lobbying firm just
down the way on k street and now you're
making five,
six,
$700,000 a year to use the influence
and the contacts that you have made as a
congressman to influence
government for the,
for the firm. You're working for it. Yeah.
I think that's the biggest problem in
America right now because I don't think
you can really address it at the other
problems until he takes care of that.
Well,
I have a friend working on a possible
option and the option instead of trying to
attack campaign finance
and its current form,
offer another option and that other
option being the internet and that the
Internet,
you could have people that were funded
by like crowdsource Kickstarter style and
have people that are promoting certain
ideas funded and that being like doing it
that way, you could have a, it's a
massive resource of human beings.
We're talking about 300
million human beings,
which you really will have access to for
the first time as opposed to if you're
trying to do it like in any other form.
Like when Ross Perot came around,
they decided to tighten the
game up completely because
he fucked up everything.
That's the reason why Clinton became
president in the first place because Ross
Perot came around and threw a giant
monkey wrench in the whole Republican side
of things and they said,
we cannot let that happen again.
So the commission for presidential
debates is a privately funded institution
decided to change their standards.
So how many people have to like you
before you're allowed to be in the debate,
like you have to have a giant percentage
of the popular vote to be able to get
into the debate.
Well,
that's the rub is you can't get it and
so you can get into the debate so you
can't get it and you can't get
it. So go fuck yourself. Yeah.
Well this idea would be another
option. Would that be you? Would the,
the people that are their hamstring
because they don't have enough money.
If someone was dedicating their time
to creating like a real network of
politicians who are sourced like entirely
by the public and accountable for all
the different things that they're saying
that they're going to represent once
they get in there.
The thing I worry about that
the thing,
I have a problem,
what worries me is that you're still then
having congressmen spending 40 50% of
their time raising funds and I would like
the government to set a or someone to
set a limit and,
and,
and Dole out money to
all candidates equally.
Oh, that's horse shit.
They're now worth equal.
Do you think that equal that come on man.
Do you think that or like think of all
the crack heads like Rick Santorum that
ran for president. I think that
motherfucker deserves equal money.
Well it was crazy.
He was the one to stop gay marriage.
Crazy people that think that the
earth is less than 10,000 years old.
They get the money too.
You get those people
getting involved when he,
because corporations like
will side with people who uh,
have their interests are how
often it might be Rick Santorum
maybe.
And maybe I'm hoping that the general
public will catch up to the idea that
that's a good idea. Yeah, you're right.
That's some prompts on
the Internet as a source.
Like that is to me another option outside
of the corporations that hasn't been
addressed yet. We've got to change that.
I think that is the, the gap for me,
that is the biggest problem.
And that's one of the things that I
like when people ask me like, you know,
what are the real problems? I started out
with campaign finance reform. Yes, yes.
That's huge. And then you know when
you have all this crazy spine going on,
but no real, I mean, what's
the real danger? What's
really going on? Where's the,
the massive amount of terrorism that
we're experiencing in our country on a
regular basis that we need to take
over people's People's privacy,
that we need to be able to fish through
everyone's email and get metadata on
every phone call you make.
Where's the fucking evidence that
there's any need for all this stuff?
I say there's very little,
and I say it's one of those things,
it's a natural progression.
When a girl blows you,
you want to stick it in her ass.
It's just what happens.
You want to see if you could do that too.
When a girl is willing
to have sex with you,
will she blow you when a girl
jerks you off? Can we now have sex?
It's just there's a normal thing. You
steal $5 at work, can I still 20 you know,
you,
you figure out a way to do
things more to get things more.
And that applies to everything that human
beings do it history of government is
that that to get to gain more control
and if they've got the power to,
to look into people's
emails, they're like, well,
let's just get all everyone's email
that they ever do ever. It's that way.
We can always have them on any,
and it's, it's, it's against the,
everyone wants to say that, well, the
constitution should be a living document.
It should change with the times, you know,
there's, we have a nuclear bombs now.
There's a lot of real issues
that people need to deal with.
They didn't have to deal with when
the constitution was written, but yes,
but the constitution,
what's interesting about it is that it's
a skeleton form of a government that
people were trying to construct after.
The governance that they had seen had
failed miserably because they were all
right darkies they were dictating.
So it was more,
it was psychologically based as well.
It understood the nature of man.
That's right. And those, those,
those fail safes that were put in place
and when they were establishing the
early government, when they were
trying to separate church and state,
what they were trying to do was make
it so that you couldn't have cults of
people with influence that just
controlled vast parts of the world.
Exactly ended eventually happened just
like they thought it was going to.
So well,
the constitution just in that
form should be respected.
Even if you don't want to,
you know,
you don't want to limit it to what was
written in the constitution because now
we have wireless internet and
all this other crazy shit.
He's still have to think they, they
saw corruption coming. They were right.
Ben Franklin said that the legend goes,
he came out and after they've formulated
the constitution and they said,
what if the woman said, what
have you done? And he said, well,
we've created a republic madam,
if you can keep it, you know,
it was always precarious.
You know,
when you write about conspiracy theories
or breakdown conspiracy theories, um,
do you feel an obligation to also
expose people to shit that actually is
legitimate? That does need concern?
That I do to a small extent,
but the so many of the people
doing the uh, the, the, you know,
I can just kinda point them
to the other sites like
campaign finance reform.
There's loads of things out there.
So I didn't really feel the need.
I think like,
because I'm doing a very
good job at debunking stuff,
that's where I focus my efforts.
Totally agree.
I think you're doing a great job,
but I also feel like you
take an exorbitant amount
of negative energy then like
I've seen these debates that you get
online with these people just on Twitter
when you jumped on Twitter,
I watch you for days.
I was coming in here to the office while
we were filming the show and I was like,
he is still going at it with these
motherfuckers and you never lost your
patients. You were all these people
are calling you a government shill.
They're asking you how much
you get paid by the government.
And he just kept throwing up like,
you know, this one asks a question,
he would give a scientific explanation,
throw up a link,
and then they would just be like,
ah,
fuck flappable got to
flappable British gentlemen.
And that's something that people
like to use it against me. They said,
I'm too unflappable.
Oh, I must be a fermentation because
I'm not saying fuck you to everybody.
You can't win. It's really important that
we look at the truth, the real truth,
not the truth that you want to see, but
the actual real truth. And there's, uh,
there's a lot of complexities to this
life and there's complexities to the mind
that we perceive this very life with.
And that's a real issue.
There has to be managed
like the constitution was
trying to manage the idea of
the psychological nature of man in, in
a, in the form of making government.
You have to kind of manage your,
your own mind in terms of how certain
situations can be defended that don't
necessarily make sense.
You and I talk about this all the time.
I mean a lot of times you've got to
face up to when you're lying or lying to
even to yourself, you've got to
face up to kind of like, oh man.
I've been kind of telling myself a story
here and actually my good friend over
here has just told me that I
got to take a look at that.
That's what a real friend
does, right? When you go home,
that's something I'm not going
to actually reassess some.
You know I love Michael Schirmer's quote.
If you've read them,
I'm doing myself a great
disjustice injustice,
but bring up Michael Shermer right now
because I'll be a rape apologist because
I don't know if you know about this. He
was accused of doing something improper,
improper meaning getting a girl
drunk and having sex with her.
Crazy that people are calling that a
lot of people are calling that rape man.
I ain't never done that.
I don't know if that happened.
I don't know what happened
getting her drunk.
So my point is that I just needed to
address that just to put it out there.
But the,
the quote that is that he has is that
lots of people that are very smart believe
dump things because they can explain
them and they can argue them very well.
And so they think they're doing
well and winning in the argument.
So that may be their point.
Makes Sense.
But it really becomes like a sort
of circular ego argument. Sounds,
sounds good. They've got a good
sounding occupant to be, you know,
you talked to like Michael Murphy
and uh, he, he's very eloquent.
Yes. It used to be, it's a bit less
eloquent now. It's, but he, he, you know,
he's very convincing.
He's very personable person and you know,
you can easily get sucked
into things like that.
And then you start repeating the same
arguments yourself and you're convincing
because if you are an eloquent person,
you're eloquent to yourself.
Well, it's also in being a smart person
and most of us are at least somewhat
competitive.
We want to be right.
And it's what you were talking about
earlier about certain skeptics being
aggressive and they use
skepticism as a game. W Ciao.
Tallying up a social score.
Yeah. It becomes a debate, uh,
in the old fashioned sense of a debate
where it's like one person has to argue
this,
the other person argues the opposite
thing and then they fight it out and the
best debater winds,
it becomes about debating rather than
about finding what is true and what is not
true.
Okay.
Yeah, that's, that is a real
problem with, uh, being able to,
to,
to put it all aside and actually like,
look at what the fuck is really going on.
They end up saying things
that are wrong because the,
the too hasty to come up with
an explanation for things.
So they'll end up like,
you know, just saying, you
know, oh, that's, that's not
cool. That's not a chem trail.
That's a smoke from the plains.
Because because that's the first thing
that comes into the hat because they're
that debunkers and they think that
if they can think of something,
they've got that thing where you know
they think they are intelligent and they
are somewhat intelligent but people fool
themselves as to how intelligent they
actually are. So even in debunkers
can you get caught? Oh yeah. Yeah,
it is their own to seats.
It's very,
it's very annoying from my perspective
as well because I get people coming onto
my site and then they try to debunk
things but that they say things that are
wrong but it's scientifically wrong and
then you have to end up like correcting
the debunkers as well.
Oh well that ever ends NTD bunkers,
we agree there are a lot of Conti d
cause quite a few, you know. Sure.
It's easily,
to me it's easy to be when you're also
frustrated with your own vision of the
world and then when someone comes along
saying they have fucking documented
proof to loch ness monster is real and
you're like the fuck you do shit head
right. You don't, it's hard. It's
hard to say what is it was Sarah,
what is this proof where we have
you got this proof stored? Right.
May I measure it?
Yeah.
That sounds like the evidence you were
asking for in that the Ufo thing last
night. Yeah, a couple of days ago.
It's, yeah, they don't have evidence.
They have eyewitness tetanus testimony
or they have like crappy photos.
There's no empirical evidence. There's
not nothing that sort of like, let's,
let's see some measurable evidence. Well,
let me tell you this. After chem trails,
which was the number one most hate I
got from anything I've ever done online,
so many people thought it was a
shill. And uh, number two was aliens.
And the idea that I could debunk like
this one place and it wasn't even deep
bunked this one place,
sky was just telling me some
crazy shit and I didn't buy it.
It's really simple when you talk to me
about bulletproof wolves and missed,
and if I don't buy it, it doesn't
mean I'm an asshole. Okay.
It means I'm trying to be real about this.
I think it's much more likely that there's
intelligent life in the universe than
it is that there isn't,
I think it's much more likely.
But I also think there's a lot
of shit that people are seeing.
Like we were talking about
these orbs people keep seeing
in this area around, um,
this ranch is little ranch, which is
in Utah, northern Utah. Well there's,
it's potentially ball lightning,
like bald lightening is a very real
phenomenon that's been measured and it's
really weird.
Like it can stay around for
several seconds sometimes
and people see it darting
around doing crazy shit.
And if you didn't expect to see that
and all of a sudden you did see it and
you're trying to put it into context and
you're looking at something that's so
fantastic, but it's really
just a phenomenon of nature.
You could convince yourself that you're
looking at something that is being
controlled by an alien life force.
And my problem is really simple.
I know people are full of Shit.
So when I meet one that might
be full of shit, I go, well,
he might be full of Shit.
It's really that simple.
It's not like lying is
something that doesn't exist.
It's not like a lot of people don't lie.
No.
The evidence is that a lot of people do
just make up stories and when someone
has,
you know,
just like the guy who's looking at the
fucking people that he's about to shoot
and sees it twitching motherfucker that
knows he's hopped up on adrenaline. Yep.
You also, as a person, especially a person
who's brutally honest with yourself,
recognize very easy when someone has no
emotional connection to the words that
are coming out of their mouth. This is
not a real incident that they're reciting.
This is not a real thing that took place.
This is a person that's
telling me a stupid story
that sucks and it's insulting.
It's insulting to me that you think I'm
so fucking dumb that this is the week
game you're playing on me.
Just like some asshole coming up to the
most beautiful woman in the world and
trying to convince her that he's
a prince. Right? Right. Yeah.
That shit is insulting and gotten my AA.
What do you gotta do it?
Right?
My point is it's insulting
and it's a problem with the,
the whole community of
quote unquote believers.
It's the problem is not that there are,
there's no way there's
Ufo is it's impossible.
The problem is most people tell Shitty
fucking stories that don't have any
evidence behind them.
They don't have anything.
And it's interesting when they tell you
these stories and if it is real wow,
amazing that the aliens came and took
you and they look just like every other
alien from Steven's Spielberg's close
encounters of the third time on and it
took you in space.
This is very common among people
who take religion at literal value.
When you see people who interpret the
Bible literally and stuff like that sort
of, but no, because these people are
talking about personal experiences.
They're having personal
experiences that way too,
and they have conversions or I'm
reborn and I had, I saw Jesus.
You hear a lot of that,
right?
But you hear much more of
people being abducted by aliens.
Then you do have people having religious
experiences and I think that goes right
back to the whole flying saucer thing.
I think people are in their head thinking
that they're going to be abducted by
aliens and so when they are sleeping,
which is when all these
fucking things take place,
they all take place the middle of
the night and they'll tell, you know,
a lot of abductions take
place during the day.
You know what else happens
during day? Sometimes naps. Yeah.
These people conk out at work and they
think they lost time cause you're fucking
drew blood on your shirt. Stupid,
right? You're not in a space ship.
You're not special.
You're gonna fucking cubicle and you're
not the person that the people from
Alpha Centauri have talked
to and convinced that you're
going to be able to have
the solution for saving the human
race out of your fucking cubicle.
You're nodding off every day.
Right.
Is that reaction you get when you
disbelieve somebody? Oh, you just,
just skeptical about them is that
they think that you're being,
you know that you're judging them, but
really you're just being, you know,
being somewhat scientific
about it. No, that's you.
I'm judging them and they were
doing very different things,
but they claim to be very open minded,
but really the pretty much the opposite
of open minded because they will only
believe that there are particular
interpretation of results and they think
because they're interpretation is
different from everybody else's.
That means that they are being open
minded just means that's a very,
very narrow minded outside
incredibly butthurt. If you
call them on it, God damn it.
No one's more butthurt then conspiracy
theorist, if you disagree with them,
it gets emotional.
So God damn fast.
Out of all the things that have
disagreed with with people,
whether it was a controversial issues
like males changing transgendered female
getting to fighting,
nothing got people more pissed off
than the chem trail thing. Yeah,
that's amazing to me. Amazing.
Amazing. In that sense,
it kind of feels as though they're,
they're less concerned about chem trails
are just an excuse to garner around an
issue that makes them feel like there's
a fight to be had. It's real simple.
They're lazy.
They're only taking a few steps for taking
a few steps and looking at things and
then the defending that position to get
into that position and then they rocked
up position hard.
The really nutty,
aggressive people that are going after
people on law and you fuck government
shoe, like you just guts go and look
at what the fuck you're talking about.
It doesn't mean the government
didn't organize Northwoods.
The government was at the Joint Chiefs
of Staff signed a document saying they
were going to fucking bomb Guantanamo Bay.
They're going to arb,
cumin friendlies and attack Guantanamo
Bay. That's a real, didn't happen.
But people do try to do shit and when
you pretend that something's happening,
that's not happening.
You cheapen everything where there's
really something going on or the burden of
proof is on you to prove
what you're saying you,
you can't just come out and say a bunch
of stuff and not have any anything I can.
But you're talking logical.
Yeah. The the the theorists, they
also, they, they go into things in too,
a lot of breadth but not depth.
So once you've debunk something,
they don't actually like, you know,
tried to come back on that thing.
They just move onto the next thing.
So you've got this, this long,
long lists of hundreds and hundreds of
hundreds of pieces of evidences. Uh,
but I've an interesting, but any
one, you can go into any depth.
You could actually prove absolutely.
That is not true. But they,
as soon as you start to get in there,
they will just drop it and
they'll move on to the next.
Yeah. It becomes a, it becomes
a weird thing in your head.
That's actually really interesting though,
that they just want it to be real.
Hi, this is this one guy who thinks
that a UV radiation is really,
really high at the moment.
And he has these,
these readings that you did with
this crappy cheap meters that he had.
This is the chem shell dude.
Yeah. You debated, this
is a 70 minute transcription, a 70
minute debate. It's really fascinating.
He read the whole thing. Yes. Yeah. I read
it off. Yeah. So he, he basically started,
I got problem.
He thinks that there's so much radiation
coming down that it's actually the
levels is measuring is more than
they're actually using in space.
Well it was interesting.
I need to watch the actual video because
I could picture it taking place like
when you would call them on things and
he had literally no response to like the,
you know, the, the differences that you
guys had between, you know, what was uh,
what was actually happening with the
sky and what was actually been proven.
Like these kind of no evidence
he's saying these claims.
It went from one thing to the next one.
You will say,
well what about the gaps in contracts
and explaining what they say. Oh,
what about these things coming off the
back of Casey tends and I would explain
what that is. And then you were
talking about the UV radiation.
That was when things got really weird.
It was like you were saying
like where's the results?
Like where are the medical
results of this changing,
this dangerous change in the environment
if the levels go away. He said,
and he's like,
they were it like 20 times normal UVB.
Which is what causes like skin
cancer on sunburn. Just reading.
It was just like a picture of the
pausing and the panic in the room.
It was so crazy. It's like used to
be, he deserves to be of course,
but he was very, very eloquent
and very well spoken when he,
when he debated is extremely
competent in his viewpoint,
but it was this very narrow viewpoint
and it would just stick to his point and
he would keep going off on
this long litany is where
he would repeat his like 12
talking point. Yeah, it's real. It's
actually scary. That's almost a sociopath.
Somebody doesn't is not
even emotional about it,
but rather just kind of like he
wants emotional though. He was,
he was very passionate about
this. Not that Brian, it's just,
it's complete conviction
in their stupid idea.
It's confirmation bias to its
extreme and complete conviction.
And I in an idea that doesn't
rejection of, of people like me,
like not just reduction
of you, but a reduction of
contradictory evidence period.
Yeah.
Because I'm the,
I'm going to a person who's
actually giving them that
contradictory evidence and
he's totally convinced that I'm a paid
shill. Yeah. He's, he's it done this long.
Are you sure you're not a paid shill? A
you do, you get checks every week and go,
where'd that come from?
My wife complains about me spending
money on my web hosting because it's,
you know,
it's coming out of our budget.
So you used to run like a computer
game companies that we, yeah. Yeah.
I never saw the Tony Hawk video games.
And you sold that and then you decided
once you sold out that you were just
going to go into hibernation. Uh, and I,
I stayed there for a few years and then
I just thought I'd go off and do other
things and ended up doing a debunking.
I didn't leave to go debunking that.
Just what I ended up doing. What you used
to own? Never soft. That's what he says.
Oh, that is amazing. Tony Hawk, we,
we grew up with Tony Hawk
and everything like that.
It's one of my favorite was one of my
favorite companies is distraction that you
created. Cool. I would talk to you
about never saw fall day. So you own,
you own that company and sold it and
then a thought of it. Oh Wow. Awesome.
So when you decided to kick back and you
know, not work anymore after he sold it,
how did
you get started in this whole
debunking thing? Did it,
was it start with one issue?
Yeah,
it started with the on Wikipedia and I
was doing crap about biblical scientific
for knowledge and that was
just kind of me doing my,
my naive debunker guy where I
saw something that was wrong.
So I started like typing a bunch of
stuff that's wrong and I'm going issue to
issue,
uh,
like point to point and just like slapping
them down and then I moved on to more
gallons, which uh, you know, you did.
Yeah,
we covered much more,
more jealous in the show then we got
the chance to put in because of the
limitations that it was
[inaudible] file apocalypse thing.
Most likely it's this two things,
most likely some people
they have a an issue with.
They're cutting their skin open and
sticking things in there and there, there,
there,
there are people that have that,
but there's also a bunch of people that
have Lyme disease and they think it's
hyperkeratinization might be occurring
Lyme disease apparently when a tick bites
you.
And this is the most recent thing from
the more gentleman's conference that I
went to an Austin up this year. So w
what they call their studies or science.
I don't know who's right or
who's wrong. Stigmata but
there's no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
The more challenge is a disease where
they get these fibers that are growing out
of their skin. Um, what,
what the doctors that have at claim is
that it's Lyme disease and they all test
positive for Lyme disease apparently.
And hyperkeratinization,
which is some sort of a side effect of
something that comes along with the Lyme
disease. And the idea is that the tick
is not just carrying one pathogen,
it's probably carrying several
and some of them even undiagnosed.
So it pygmies or a piggy backs
rather along with Lyme disease.
This is what the doctors had habit belief.
Well yeah,
but those are the same guys that
basically kind of invented it in the first
place. That, that one guy that you told
her, that kind of twitchy guy. Yes. Uh,
he invented it and they didn't invent it,
but he was part of the
Morgellons research foundation,
which doesn't exist anymore,
which is an original group of people
who kind of like promoted it and got it
into the, into the media, uh,
back about, you know, six,
seven years ago when I got the CDC to
investigator when really it isn't very
much evidence to say that it is a
distinct disease at all. So that was,
that was kind of what I was debunking
was that the people saying the walls
evidence, the, the, some thing going
on when really there wasn't it.
So these doctors that are saying
that this is hypercare team,
we're running out of time,
uh, about four minutes. Dammit.
We could go on about this forever.
I really need to talk to you about
this because this is quite fascinating
because they were having me convinced
that it's something to do with Lyme
disease. Yeah. Not The big theory.
Like what, but one of the doctors,
what are they getting these
sores all over their body?
Then what do you think it is?
It's a neurotic excoriation systemical
to investigate the scratching themselves,
but how they do it in spots on their
back that can't even read it. They can.
They can.
Those photos of people who happened,
your Arctic explorations
on the back of the day,
they match exactly the patterns
of the people who, uh, who have,
what about the people that show these
extra hairs that are coming out?
They've taken photographs of these like
five and six clumps of hair that are
like popping out of these areas what
they're calling hyperkeratinization.
You think that's bullshit too?
No,
that's probably just a
normal dermatological
condition. Like people just,
they have articles and get,
but they're saying that that's occurring
and a lot of their little sores. Yeah.
Now that that's just a
lot of those just fibers
getting caught in this and we're going
to have to do this again sometime.
God dammit. Yeah, we have too much shit
to talk about. We can keep going on.
I'll talk to you about just more jealous
for the next 20 minutes and people were
like, Yay. People at
the, on the, on the uh,
treadmills right now. I'm going, yeah,
I was hoping you were going to talk about
festering fucking diseases of the skin.
I can, there's 20 minutes to
class next. I'll listen man.
It's been very interesting. Thank you
very much. Let's do it again for sure.
Come back and we'll find
some more shit to do.
Bunk and hopefully I can get somebody
who believes in chem trails that believes
that government is spraying.
There is evidence to come here and do it.
I tried but they all passed or the one
that I tried that I reached out to past.
There it is ladies and gentlemen,
folks, we'll be back later this week.
Most likely tomorrow.
I'm working on my schedule.
Thanks to squarespace.com
go to squarespace.com use
the code word Joe and the
number nine, all one word,
Joe and the number nine.
Save yourself 10% off and go to legal
zoom.com dot [inaudible] dot com that's
what,
that's what happens when I read and
talk@thesametimeafterbulletproofcoffeeandalegalzoom.com.
Use the code word Rogan.
Save some money as well as on it.
Use Code new word Rogan. Save 10% off
any and all supplements. All right,
we'll be back soon. And uh, until
then, big kiss say in Raleigh.